triste et sénateurs présents mais
également celles et ceux qui sont
derrière leur écran monsieur le ministre
nous sommes heureux de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui pour cette audition devant
notre commission de la culture de la
communication
et bien sûr de l'éducation et nous
sommes particulièrement honorés que vous
ayez choisi le sénat comme d'ailleurs
votre collègue rima à bulles malak pour
effectuer votre première intervention
devant une commission parlementaire
c'est pour nous l'occasion de vous
adresser nos plus sincères félicitations
pour votre nomination à la tête du
ministère et un plein succès bien
entendu dans vos fonctions
ministérielles comme vous le savez
certainement notre commission a toujours
prêté une attention toute particulière
aux sujets liés à l'éducation et à la
jeunesse
notre attitude avec vos différents
prédécesseur s'est toujours voulue
constructive nous avons d'ailleurs
réussi à trouver au cours de la dernière
législature des points d'accord tant
avec nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale qu avec le gouvernement sur
deux textes significatif je pense à la
loi pour une école de la confiance en
2019 et plus récemment la loi relative
aux fonctions de directrice ou de
directeur d'école je forme le voeu bien
entendu que dans les semaines et les
mois à venir nous puissions être en
mesure de préserver voire de renforcer
ce dialogue certains diront cette co
construction législatives dans l'intérêt
des élèves et de l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative les sujets auxquels
notre commission s'est teinté pardon
intéressé dans le cadre de sa mission de
contrôle témoignent de la diversité des
problématiques rencontrées par le
système éducatif français dès 2012 nous
identifions un profond malaise chez les
enseignants du pays six ans plus tard
notre nos collègues par max pression et
françoise laborde alertait sur la baisse
d'attractivité du métier appelé à la
mise en place d'un nouveau cadre
d'exercices de celui ci au regard des
nombreuses places vacantes dans les
derniers concours de recrutement des
professeurs et singulièrement dans les
académies de créteil et de versailles
leur recommandation reste plus que
jamais actualité je souhaite également
salué les travaux de la mission
d'information sur la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et le cyber
harcèlement présidée par notre collègue
sabine van heghe de très nombreux
membres de notre commission et y ont
participé
la loi visant à lutter contre le
harcèlement scolaire ne permettra
malheureusement pas à elle seule de
combattre ce fléau que seule une
mobilisation générale est une
application de tous pour à roddick et
notre commission a par ailleurs
identifié très tôt les principaux
problèmes d'articulations en particulier
calendaire entre la réforme de parcours
su et celle du lycée et du baccalauréat
nous aurons certainement l'occasion de
discuter également de ce sujet avec
votre collègue en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur même si bill
retailleau que nous auditionneront la
semaine prochaine je souhaite néanmoins
vous alerter sur le fait que ni
l'éducation nationale ni l'enseignement
supérieur n'ont tiré toutes les
conséquences de ces réformes et nous y
reviendrons certainement à travers nos
questions le bilan des mesures
éducatives du précédent quinquennat
dressé par nos collègues annick billon
max brisson et marie pierre monnier l'a
souligné la réforme du lycée s'est
arrêté au milieu du gué que ce soit en
matière d'accompagnement l'orientation
des élèves et d'égalité entre
établissements dans les spécialités
options proposées
le rapport montre d'ailleurs que si de
nombreuses réformes en matière éducative
ont été lancés beaucoup d'interrogations
demeurent je pense ici au dédoublement
des classes de grande section en ce1 en
éducation prioritaire et au plafonnement
à 24 élèves pour ces mêmes niveaux dans
les autres écoles la différence entre
les moyens nécessaires pour mener à bien
ces deux réformes et le nombre de tp
créer de plus de douze mille deux cents
exactement le en matière de sport à
l'école jacques grosperrin
notre rapporteur pour avis des crédits
enseignement scolaire a alerté l'année
dernière sur le manque de moyens
consacrés à cette politique le principe
d'une activité sportive quotidienne à
l'école primaire a été inscrite dans la
loi bien sûr nous la soutenons aligner
puisque c'était une initiative du sénat
elle doit entrer en vigueur dès cette
rentrée le gouvernement appelle à bâtir
une nation sportive il ya utiliser les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques comme
accélérateur de l'activité sportive dans
notre pays or actuellement à peine la
moitié des heures de ps sont effectués
il s'agit là d'un des nombreux sujets
dont il vous faudra vous emparer dans
les meilleurs délais mais ce mini je
vais vous laisser la parole pour un
propos introductif d'une dizaine de
minutes et puis après si vous le voulez
bien nous fonctionnerons sous forme de
questions-réponses doute pas que mes
collègues ont de nombreuses questions à
vous poser et que comprendrait bien sûr
le temps de rapporter les éléments de
réponse que vous souhaitez donc sans
plus tarder je vous laisse la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs je
vous remercie très vivement de cette
invitation à m'exprimer devant votre
commission la commission de la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication
pour avoir été longtemps membre du jury
du concours des administrateurs du sénat
je connais un peu votre prestigieuse est
utile institutions et je me réjouis de
pouvoir échanger avec vous sur des
sujets essentiels pour notre pays et son
avenir est changé et je reprends votre
mot monsieur le président co construire
en effet en avec vous je vais dans cette
très brève présentation tracé quelques
grands axes des
de la politique que nous mettons y
allons mettre en oeuvre et je serai très
heureux de répondre à des questions plus
spécifiques sur un certain nombre de
points que vous voudrez bien évoqué il
compte les points que vous venez
d'évoquer monsieur le président le
premier point que je voudrais souligner
en continuité avec
le quinquennat précédent et celui des
savoirs fondamentaux de l'accent mis sur
les savoirs fondamentaux
le français les mathématiques dont des
études avaient montré que nous
enregistrions des déficiences
problématique en particulier
à l'entrée au collège et bien au delà
est donc cet accent mis sur les savoirs
fondamentaux à la fois à l'école
élémentaire mais aussi dans
l'enseignement secondaire
également sur la pédagogie de ces
savoirs fondamentaux
s'inscrit en prolongation de ce qui a
été fait et bien fait
du côté de l'école élémentaire mais
aussi du côté du lycée nous avons
récemment 9h30 supplémentaires une heure
et demie de mathématiques dans le tronc
commun des
deux classes de première
sous forme facultative avant de
l'introduire vraisemblablement sous une
forme
obligatoire à partir de la rentrée 2023
compte tenu du niveau en mathématiques
des élèves de 1re et de la nécessité de
proposer des mathématiques y compris à
celles et ceux qui ne se spécialiseront
pas dans un domaine lié à cette
discipline le deuxième point sur lequel
je voudrais insister c'est celui de
l'égalité des chances et des politiques
de réduction des inégalités
sociales vous savez à cet égard que la
position de la france en comparaison de
ce qui est enregistré et mesuré ailleurs
en particulier en europe n'est pas très
enviable de ce point et nous ne pouvons
pas nous satisfaire de cette situation
j'ai lu avec intérêt à cet égard le
rapport du sénateur longuet qui
recommande entre autres points
d'accentuer les comparaisons
internationales
au sein de mon ministère est de
s'appuyer sur ces comparaisons pour en
tirer des enseignements utiles
ces politiques d'égalité des chances se
décline de différentes manières à la
fois par la poursuite du dédoublement
des classes nous avons à cet égard pour
les classes de cp et ce1 en rep est
raide plus des indications tout à fait
intéressante sur le recul du nombre
d'élèves en difficulté un recul de 16%
dans les derniers travaux que nous avons
sur également la poursuite du
dédoublement dans les classes de grande
section d'école maternelle celles ci
sont dédoublés aux trois quarts on est à
74 % toujours en rep et ré plus dans la
limitation du nombre d'élèves en classe
de 6ème dans des expériences ou dans des
projets de mixité sociale en particulier
dans les villes ou dans les régions où
cette mixité est peu présente et
également dans la réflexion que nous
entreprenons sur la carte de
l'enseignement prioritaire qui a empilé
les dispositifs au fil des ans et qui
doit faire un autre sens l'objet d'une
réflexion globale et un peu systémique
le troisième point que je voudrais
mentionner c'est celui du bien-être des
élèves qui n'est pas antithétiques du de
l'effort du travail
l'école est bien le lieu de l'effort et
du travail mais elle peut elle doit être
aussi le lieu du bien-être cette
question est d'autant plus sensible
aujourd'hui
que la santé physique et surtout la
santé psychique de nos jeunes ne laisse
pas d'inquiéter nous avons des données
qui sont préoccupantes quant à cette
santé et quant aux effets aussi de la
crise sanitaire sur la santé de nos
élèves et nous devons nous y pencher 5
lui bien sûr une réflexion sur la santé
scolaire dont vous savez que l'état est
préoccupant jeu pourra y revenir si vous
le souhaitez et d'une manière générale
sur des activités qui favorise le
bien-être des élèves ce qui inclut
également les activités physiques
activité physique sport etc
le quatrième point que je voudrais
mentionner c'est la question de
l'environnement de l'écologie c'est une
des grandes priorités du quinquennat qui
s'ouvre point n'est besoin d'insister
sur l'urgence de ces questions qui ne
peuvent être seulement limité à un
ministère aussi important et
au premier plan soit il mais qui à mon
sens doit irriguer aussi la politique et
les ambitions du ministère de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
et vous savez également l'implication de
la jeunesse sur les questions liées à
l'environnement qui parlent directement
à son avenir et qui sont une forme
d'entrée dans la citoyenneté pour elle
nous devons avec et en premier lieu
l'attention le soutien et la
coordination avec les collectivités
territoriales qui sont directement
responsables de cela je veux dire le
bâti le bâti scolaire nous devons
engager une réflexion en étroite
concertation car le bâti scolaire et
nous en avons des témoignages éloquents
lors de la dernière vague de chaleur
en juin n'est pas toujours bien adaptée
aux évolutions climatiques
il y a également la question des
programmes scolaires
j'ai demandé à l'inspection générale de
se pencher sur la manière dont les
questions d'environnement de
développement durable et d'écologie sont
saisis dans les programmes et puis il y
a également ce qui existe et qui est de
grand intérêt à savoir la labellisation
e3d des établissements les éco-délégués
tout cela doit être mis en valeur et
encore une fois à notre sens c'est une
manière de mobiliser et d'intéresser nos
jeunes sur des questions évidemment
essentielles sur lesquelles la
connaissance
l'enseignement le savoir ont évidemment
un rôle primordial le cinquième point je
vais m'arrêter là c'est celui que vous
avez évoquées monsieur le président de
la revalorisation des enseignants je
dirais d'une revalorisation globale la
place des enseignants dans notre société
leur rémunération les difficultés de
recrutement que vous avez très justement
souligné
tout cela fait l'objet de notre part de
travaux à commencer évidemment par la
question de la revalorisation financière
il ya un enjeu ici qui est tout à fait
important et j'y ajoute en lien avec
cela une réflexion aussi sur la
pédagogie sur l'innovation pédagogique
beaucoup de pays d'europe du nord ont
engagé des formes de réflexion
pédagogique qui sont tout à fait
intéressante qui mobilise en particulier
les collectifs plutôt que le singulier
dans la relation avec les classes et
cela peut s'inscrire dans une politique
de revalorisation de la profession
enseignante elle même enchâssé dans ce
dans ce qui a été annoncé par le
président de la république à propos du
plan marseillan grands du projet
marseillais et de tout ce que
nous allons engager cet automne quant à
l'innovation pédagogique
l'autonomie
raisonnable que nous allons penser pour
les établissements scolaires tout cela
est aussi en jeu dans les débats et dans
la réflexion que nous engageons cet
automne dans le cadre fixé par le
président de la république et la
première ministre voilà quelques-uns des
axes que je voulais souligner et je suis
bien entendu à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions il ce sera un
plaisir et un honneur mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs monsieur le président si
monsieur le ministre et nous allons
commencer à dire comme à l'accoutumée
par nos deux rapporteurs en l'occurrence
jacques grosperrin qui rapporteur pour
avis des crédits liés à l'enseignement
scolaire et ensuite interviendra jacques
bernard magner qui lui est rapporteur
pour avis des crédits jeunesse jacques
bernard magner doit être derrière son
écran merci président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme le
président l'a dit précédemment c'est un
honneur en tout cas un plaisir de vous
recevoir dans cette haute assemblée et
nous vous en remercions
vous êtes bénis d'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et c'est vrai que cette
responsabilité
cette nomination vous confère une
responsabilité éminente dans la
république celle de l'émancipation par
le savoir la première ministre avait
affirmé d'ailleurs mercredi soir qu'elle
n'imaginait pas la république sans le
sénat nous non plus d'ailleurs elle a
justement appelé à s'inspirer
d'expériences dessinateur fausse
d'apaisement et de voix des élus locaux
et des territoires elle a en même temps
parler de la refondation de l'école on
l'entend depuis 2013 ce n'est pas
rassurant vous ne serez donc pas étonné
qu'on fermement nos traditions à nos
méthodes que nos questions exige rigueur
et précision dans les réponses sont des
coûts en tout cas les conditions
indispensables au dialogue à la
construction de la confiance nos
inquiétudes sont multiples sur la
situation de l'économie d'autres pays
vous ne vous êtes pas réellement
exprimés sous les polémiques liées à
certains de vos propos passés en tout
cas de travaux de recherche je cite par
exemple l'universalisme chauvin hommes
blancs hétérosexuels
être français c'est encore être blanc
être nos blancs c'est être ailleurs vos
déclarations sur ces sujets ont toujours
été approuvé et utilisé par tous ceux
qui considèrent qu'il ya un racisme
d'état en france et vous savez une des
cibles préférées des idéologues de la
race et l'école accusé d'être le lieu où
se construirait une norme raciste
française racisme structurel ou racisme
systémique vous êtes un excellent
historiens un professeur de grande
qualité un dilemme en tout cas se pose
vous risquez de perdre votre crédibilité
universitaire si vous preniez vos
travaux et en même temps votre pilotage
sera-t-il la conséquence directe est
mécanique de vos travaux de recherche et
maintenant vous êtes ministres éducation
nationale donc vous êtes ministre pour
rassembler l'ensemble de la nation
française monsieur le ministre le sénat
vous donne aujourd'hui l'occasion de
vous exprimer plus clairement votre
accession à ce ministère est considéré
par beaucoup comme une rupture avec
l'esprit laïc et républicain qui
incarnait votre prédécesseur votre autre
prédécesseur celui à la présidence a
cité nationale de l'histoire de
l'immigration monsieur stora exprime
assez la question je le cite vos propos
flirtant avec l'indigénisme ne sont pas
capables avec l'éloge de la république
qui a été le veau durant la passation de
pouvoir vous allez devoir choisir vous
êtes un symbole ne dirige pas
l'éducation nationale à coups de
symboles et par contraste avec
jean-michel beaucaire lune le veut
imaginer un cadre ayant un calendrier de
logique cacher mais sortait du silence
et d'une prudence qui dessert d'ores et
déjà la xoom unica peuvent les amener
d'autres questions doivent être ensuite
vous êtes adressé vous êtes aux
commandes désormais quelle feuille de
route continuité ou rupture
votre pilotage sera-t-il la conséquence
j'ai dit tout à l'heure et mécanique de
vos travaux de recherche quels sont vos
moyens vos marges de manoeuvre
concernant tout d'abord les conditions
la prochaine rentrée plus de 4000 postes
n'ont pas été pourvus à l'issue des
concours pour la rentrée 2022 sur un
total de plus de 27000 cette crise
renforce le recrutement de contractuels
vous avez parlé de remplacer les profs
par d'autres réquisitionnés pour cela
attention à l'effet allègre ils feront
re conquérir le coeur des enseignants
qui indique en tout cas un malaise
professionnelle monsieur ministre y aura
t'il bien un enseignant devant chaque
classe en septembre en prenez vous
l'engagement sur la hausse indispensable
des rémunérations vous avez indiqué
qu'elle pourrait se faire en deux
parties renvoyant les précisions du
montant aux discussions budgétaires à
l'assemblée nationale mais si au sénat
quels sont les objectifs budgétaires de
votre ministère était liée à la volonté
du pied dans la république d'une mise en
concurrence des établissements
affirmé que l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant est un problème européen il
n'est pas une réponse adaptée aux
interrogations qui pèsent sur votre
ministère enfin nous classements
internationaux devenus indigents
vous l'avez dit démontre un déclassement
qui rage et rejaillit sur les
enseignants eux-mêmes stature mans et
socialement des sons du temps ou
politiques ont été menées précédemment
la revalorisation passe nécessairement
par l'affirmation de l'autorité la
discipline au sein de l'école d'autres
question pourrait être soulevée par mes
collègues la réforme du lycée et
l'engagement du lycée professionnel il
n'y a pas de ministre l'école
élémentaire la priorité de nos
fondamentaux l'apprentissage au codage
numérique la place du côté scientifique
et enfin le sénat sera à vos côtés pour
travailler à des solutions mais cette
volonté nécessite contrepartie balayé
les préalables posés les conditions
d'efficacité l'école républicaine les
enjeux sont cruciaux pour nos enfants
vos prédécesseurs jean michel blanquer
vincent peillon en 2012 avait été
préparé à occuper ce poste est souvent
ce qu'il voulait y faire avec des
priorités clairement affichée on ne peut
s'en remettre au pragmatisme et à une
navigation à vue quelles sont vos
priorités il faut du temps pour voir les
résultats vous avez compris monsieur le
ministre aujourd'hui exprimez vous et
rassurez nous
je vais donner la parole également à
jacques bernard magner qui est donc
rapporteur par important pour avis des
crédits budgétaires sur la jeunesse
jacques bernard
merci
monsieur vis mes chers collègues
j'ai entendu ce qui nous avait dit
ambühl vous êtes aussi ministre de la
jeunesse si vous n'avez pas évoquer les
dossiers concernent la jeunesse de
tout particulièrement aux ministères des
jeunes est si vous avez manqué les jeux
nes en prenant de 10 questions moi je
voudrais vous parler de 2,2 points de
service national universel
et les colonies de vacances pour les
enfants
comme vous le savez à 110 millions
d'euros ont été prévus pour cinquante
mille jeunes en 2022 pour ce service
national universel qui pour l'instant ne
concerne que des jeunes volontaires
pensez vous que cette prévision
budgétaire pourra être réalisée parce
que je suis maintenant elle ne l'a
jamais été
que pensez vous de ce dispositif auquel
il semble bien que seuls le président de
la république croit
pensez vous aussi que la généralisation
de ces nuls sera possible puisque
jusqu'à maintenant on a mal à trouver
les volontaires et quand il faudra
envoyer 750 à 800 milles jeunes en
service national universel donc
obligatoire pour un coût de près de plus
de 2 milliards d'euros
réaliste et que pensez vous aussi de la
codirection avec le ministère de la
défense s'est pas toujours c'est assez
original de voir couplée à la défense
qui concerne la jeunesse
ensuite je voudrais vous parler des
colonies de vacances on le sait depuis
de nombreuses années ces colonies de
vacances qui concerne les enfants de
gros de 2,6 à à 12-13 ans
connaissent des difficultés on a une
baisse d'effectif considérable dans les
dernières années et il semble bien que
rien ne soit fait aujourd'hui pour
essayer de redonner un peu de dynamisme
à ce secteur d'activités périscolaires
de loisirs mais aussi de citoyenneté
parce que je pense qu'il est quand même
plus intéressant d'essayer de rassembler
des enfants entre 9 et 12 ans et leur
apporter des éléments de citoyenneté
plutôt que d'attendre qu'ils aient 15 à
17 ans dans le cadre du service national
universel puisque ces gens l'objectif la
citoyenneté que prévoyez-vous de dean
ici pour combattre ce manque que deux
fils d'afrique tation
fiction plutôt d'aider des enfants et
leurs familles pour les colonies de
vacances et aussi pour moyens
d'encadrement qui semble être difficiles
à recruter aujourd'hui compte tenu des
problèmes qu'on peut avoir pour la
formation des jeunes animateurs
y at-il aujourd'hui que des encadrants
pour le service national universel qui
coûte cher et qui n'apparaît pas une
très bonne solution je vous remercie
mais si je vais vous proposer de
répondre à ces deux premières séries de
questions qui bien sûr après nous
continuerons
très bien je vous remercie
messieurs les sénateurs je vais donc
commencer monsieur le sénateur
grosperrin par vous répondre pour
d'abord
vous invitez si ce n'est pas déjà fait à
lire mes ouvrages vous n'en avez
peut-être pas le temps je le conçois
bien mais il est important de se plonger
dans la réflexion et de ne pas
simplement extraire des citations que
j'ai vu circuler à droite et à gauche y
compris d'ailleurs des citations en tout
cas des choses que je rejette
personnellement par exemple la notion de
racisme d'état je ne l'utilisent pas et
je les mêmes combattu en ce qui concerne
la france j'avais donné dans le monde
une interview à ce sujet pour expliquer
qu' il n'y a pas de racisme d'état en
france dont je ne vois pas pourquoi on
m'accuserait ou en tout cas on
m'interpelle rey à ce sujet de même que
la notion d'universalisme chauvin
laquelle vous faites allusion fait
allusion à des situations passées les
situations de l' empire colonial lorsque
la république de la troisième république
se réclamaient d'un universalisme qui
était limité puisque cet universalisme
n'accordait pas le droit où les mêmes
droits à tout le monde vous voyez que en
regardant spécifiquement les situations
historiques ou en contextualisant les
propos on trouve en fait des choses qui
sont d'ailleurs relativement admise du
côté du monde de la recherche
universitaire
croyez bien que je suis un esprit et un
citoyen laïque est parfaitement
républicain j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire à quel point j'étais moi même un
enfant de la république que je devais à
peu près tout au fond à l'école publique
qui m'a élevée
d'un échelon à l'autre et cela j'en suis
tout à fait persuadé mais vous voyez
vous je suis aussi parmi celles et ceux
qui estiment que lutter contre les
différentes formes de discrimination qui
existe dans notre pays c'est quelque
chose qui fait l'objet d'ailleurs de
politique officielle que lutter contre
les racismes contre l'antisémitisme que
lutter contre la haine anti lgbt sa
n'affaiblit pas l'arrêt fut la
république mais ça la renforce c'est une
manière de au contraire d'exprimer
concrètement son attachement aux valeurs
qui sont les nôtres celles de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité et aussi de
laïcité j'insiste sur ce point est donc
tous mes travaux de recherche si vous
avez la patience de vous y plonger au
fond témoigne de quelque chose de plus
important que moi même quelque chose qui
dépasse ma personne c'est mon
attachement à la république et à ses
valeurs c'est mon attachement une
république mais une république qui soit
fidèle à ses valeurs qui sont celles des
droits humains c'est une république qui
ne se contente pas de
d'inscrire ces
déclarations magnifique
au frontispice des bâtiments mais qui
les met en oeuvre et en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse je ne suis pas simplement
attaché à la lettre mais aussi à la mise
en oeuvre des politiques de justice des
politiques visant à combattre les
assignations de naissance donc monsieur
le sénateur je puis vous assurer que
healy a au fond des formes de continuité
même s'il ya une rupture dans dans mes
fonctions mais qu'il ya une forme de
continuité entre ce sur quoi j'ai
travaillé et ce à quoi je travaille
aujourd'hui il y à une continuité dans
mon attachement aux valeurs de la
république et est également dans mon
attachement à la lutte contre les
injustices et toutes les formes
d'injustice ensuite
continuité ou rupture
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que je ne
voyais pas les choses de cette manière
au sens où fort heureusement j'espère
échapper à une vision simpliste qui
serait celle justement du virage à 180
degrés ou de la continuité parfaite j'ai
souligné à quel point il y avait des
éléments de continuité forte avec mon
prédécesseur par exemple la poursuite
des savoirs fondamentaux l'accent mis
sur le français les mathématiques le
dédoublement la réforme des lycées
parcours sup tout cela me semble bel et
bon et je le soutiens je serais ravi
d'ailleurs de répondre à vos questions
si vous avez des demandes à ce sujet et
puis heureusement sinon mon prédécesseur
serait devant vous il y a des points
d'inflexion j'en ai cité quelques-uns et
donc j'ai échappé nous allons échapper à
cette alternative qui serait
tout ou rien ou en tout cas le virage
complet ou la continuité complète
sur les conditions de la prochaine
rentrée en effet notre objectif c'est
bien qu'il y ait un enseignant devant
chaque classe et vous savez je le
reconnais je lui dis les difficultés que
nous avons pour recruter des enseignants
qui sont des difficultés ancien mais qui
ont été accrus par des éléments plus
conjoncturelle en particulier le passage
du recrutement du m1 ou m2 et donc nous
avons une politique actuelle qui est
celle de recrutement d'enseignants
contractuels qui ne sont pas recrutés
comme j'ai pu le lire ici et là en 30
minutes
non ils sont ils font l'objet depuis
plusieurs mois de procédures de
recrutement de contrats qui ont été
prolongées pour fidéliser les
enseignants contractuels qui s'acquitte
bien de leurs tâches de formation
également de suivi et de mentorat tout
au long de leur travail tout en
reconnaissant que la situation n'est pas
idéale en effet nous devons réfléchir
structurellement comme je l'indiquais
sur les rémunérations je vous rejoins
aussi sur l'importance des classements
internationaux
il nous faut regarder évalué j'aurais dû
le mentionner dans mon introduction la
politique d'évaluation va aussi de pair
bien sûr avec celle des classements
internationaux
monsieur le sénateur
pardon excusez moi manier toutes mes
excuses monsieur le sénateur manier vous
avez souligné deux points qui
relève effectivement de ce ministère
peut-être la nouvelle secrétaire d'état
viendra-t-elle développer plus encore
que moi ces points puisqu'il lui sont
échues je pense à sarah et l'aillerie
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et au
service national universel mais je vous
répondrai volontiers un mot simplement
sur le budget du s est nu qui est de 40
millions d'euros cette année qui sera
vraisemblablement également de 40
millions d'euros nous avons et nous
l'avons reconnu des difficultés
d'organisation relatives aux essais nul
il ya un certain nombre de points qui
nous sont remontés et nous devons
réfléchir à une meilleure organisation
du ses nus à différents degrés les
choses ne fonctionnent pas comme nous le
souhaitons et donc nous devons avancer
là dessus nous sommes à 40 mille jeunes
environ pour cette année c'est une
progression notable par rapport à
l'année dernière et la pente de
progression
sera
confirmé en quelque sorte dans les
années à venir mais nous nous devons
réfléchir très sérieusement sur
l'organisation du service national
universel
quant à la co organisation avec le
ministère de la défense puisque madame
elle a hérité en effet à
agrafer si je veux dire dans son
secrétariat d'état sur le ministère de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
et le ministère des armées il y a deux
points a souligné peut-être le premier
c'est que les armées participent déjà au
s est nu par exemple les délégués
militaires départementaux sont très
actifs comme j'ai pu le voir en dordogne
il y a quelques jours dans
l'organisation des séjours vous
connaissez les capacités logistiques et
d'organisation
des armées et elles sont présentes
depuis le début et donc il y a une forme
de confirmation institutionnelle qui va
favoriser les transversalité entre les
ministères concernés par ailleurs il n'y
a pas à mon sens de militarisation comme
j'ai pu le lire également ici et là il
n'est pas question d'apprendre à manier
les armes ou quoi que ce soit de ce
genre donc une je ne vois pas ce qu'il y
a deux militaires dans les activités qui
sont proposées aux jeunes aux jeunes qui
d'ailleurs sont très satisfaits de ce
qu'ils auraient proposé j'ai pu moi même
m'en rendre compte vous avez un point
souligné un point tout à fait important
qui est un point de vigilance et de
préoccupation pour nous c'est la
difficulté à recruter des encadrants
pour les séjours qui sont ceux des
colonies de vacances des colonies
apprenantes des différents systèmes et
différents dispositifs qui sont mises en
place pour nos jeunes cet été c'est une
difficulté qui ne vous surprend pas tant
elle est devenue courante dans de très
nombreux domaines professionnels on a
beaucoup de mal à recruter et à encadrer
et c'est évidemment un sujet pour nous
ça concerne un peu moins peut-être le et
ses nus que d'autres dispositifs siph de
l'été puisque la ceni fait appel à
beaucoup d'encadrants qui sont détachés
de
2 soit deux cornes uniforme par exemple
des douaniers des sapeurs pompiers
des fonctionnaires un titre ou un autre
donc de ce point de vue là on y arrive à
peu près mais vous avez raison sur le
point général qui est celui de
l'encadrement on observe d'ailleurs
cette année une reprise du du nombre de
colonies et d'enfants intéressés de
familles intéressées par les colonies de
vacances mais on se heurte à ce problème
d'encadrement et donc c'est évidemment
un point sur lequel nous devons
réfléchir tout comme le point précédent
relatif au recrutement et aux
rémunérations des enseignants je vous
remercie alors vous êtes 18 ou 19 avoir
des questions à poser donc je vais vous
demander d'être le plus synthétique
possible sachant qu'en plus un certain
nombre d'entre vous ont des avions des
trains à apprendre je vais commencer par
un représentant par groupe et puis après
les autres interviendront et on commence
avec max brisson je vais essayer mais ce
président de répondre à votre sanction
mais ça va être un peu difficile
ceux de ministre vous avez plusieurs
avoir parlé d'eux je vous cite votre
prédécesseur
vous parliez d'un gain de jean michel
blanquer
quand il me semblait que vous avez du
mal à prononcer le nom
vous avez dit que vous situer
dans la continuité de celui ci
est d'ailleurs celui qui est à vos côtés
symbolise cette continuité
mais vous avez dit vous s'est constitué
dans l'évolution par rapport à janvier
bancaire et un certain nombre de vos
propos dans votre intervention
préliminaire le souligne certainement or
sachez monsieur ministre au sénat nous
nous prononçons sur les actes
sur les décisions et sans a priori c'est
bien ainsi qu'au nom du groupe l'est
républicain je vais vous poser une série
de questions sur le sujet
d'abord l'autonomie des établissements
le président d'un cran lors de la
campagne précédant le premier tour
lorsqu'il était candidat à proposer de
donner plus d'autonomie aux écoles aux
établissements et aux équipes éducatives
comment comptez-vous mettre en oeuvre
cet engagement
l'autonomie sera t-elle général ou
prendra-t-elle la forme de
l'expérimentation dans des
établissements particulier quelles sont
les modalités de concertation avec les
communautés éducatives que vous entendez
mettre en oeuvre pour éviter le blocage
allez-vous avoir besoin du support de la
loi vous vous contenterez vous usez du
domaine réglementaire
comment régler la question des écoles
primaires élémentaires et maternelles
qui n'ont pas la personnalité morale
pour vivre vraiment l'autonomie en marge
du sujet de l'autonomie quel regard
portez vous sur les apports de la loire
il à rilhac pardon sur l'autorité
fonctionnelle des directeurs quel sens
précis donnez vous à ce concept ne
serait-il pas plus simple de basculer
vers l'autorité hiérarchique
deuxième sujet les savoirs fondamentaux
dont vous avez parlé tout le monde est
d'accord sur l'importance de leur pleine
maîtrise fort soucier de constater leur
dégradation qui ne cesse de se
poursuivre notamment en mathématiques et
en français la réponse de votre
prédécesseur fut affecté plus de moyens
en maternelle et primaire en zone
d'éducation prioritaire par le
dédoublement des classes
la drpp nous a dit que les résultats
étaient mitigés
vous semblez vouloir les poursuivre
est-ce que cela ne pas se perdre et ne
passerait t-il pas par une réflexion sur
les finalités de l'école maternelle et
sur la formation des professeurs des
écoles maternelles qui me semblent était
le grand absent de la période précédente
troisièmement monsieur le ministre
n'est-il pas temps de renouveler le
partenariat entre l'éducation nationale
et les collectivités locales ne
serait-il pas temps de la de
l'expérimentation envisagée
de donner une autorité hiérarchique aux
présidents des départements et de
régions sur les gestionnaires des
établissements scolaires quel est votre
point de vue sur le transfert aux
départements de la médecine scolaire
afin de créer un véritable bloc de santé
scolaire quatrième sujet des professeurs
le dernier rapport que j'ai livré avec
un billion et marie pierre monier a
montré la dégradation du niveau de leurs
rénumération par rapport à leurs
collègues européens il est donc
indispensable de revaloriser
financièrement les professeurs comment
envisagez-vous cette revalorisation
quelle trajectoire allez vous leur
proposez et selon quelles modalités le
président a parlé par ailleurs de lier
une partie de cette revalorisation à
l'exercice de missions nouvelles quelles
sont elles pouvez vous préciser cette
annonce la revalorisation financière
n'est pas le seul moyen de renouer avec
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
quels moyens comptez vous utiliser pour
mettre un terme aux bizutages
institutionnels des jeunes professeurs
qui sont nommés dans les territoires où
le métier le plus difficile à exercer
envisagez-vous l'introduction de
dispositifs de contractualisation
pour amener les professeurs les plus
chevronnés allait servir dans les
territoires qui ont des besoins
éducatifs les plus forts pensez vous
monsieur le ministre que les formations
dispensées dans les aspects soient à la
hauteur des enjeux auxquels sont
confrontés les jeunes professeurs dans
certains territoires de notre république
pour défendre les valeurs de république
comment réussir à léry armé
intellectuellement pour qu'ils sont en
capacité de faire face aux dangers qui
menacent la république et pour permettre
à l'école de porter les valeurs de la
république ten trois dernières questions
rapides parce que voir le président
s'agace et monsieur le ministre comment
repenser l'éducation prioritaire
faut-il revoir les zonages donner la
main au recteur n'est-il pas utile de
mieux associer les collectivités
territoriales
qu'elle est quelles réformes
envisagez-vous pour des cas pas très
déprimé lisez les abbés sache enfin
qu'ils sont très simples les jardins
d'enfants doivent disparaître
prochainement quelle est votre position
sur le sujet seriez vous prêt à
envisager une modification des termes de
la loi pour éviter leur disparition
voyez qu au sénat le ministre on attend
des actes et c'est sur ces actes que
nous proposerons de travailler
l'expression vient de nous envoyer un
défi fou trouver des questions qu'il n'a
pas posé donc on va commencer par un
aiguillon merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le ministre pour avoir
déjà répondu extrêmement clairement à
nos deux précédentes question d'abord
félicitations pour votre nomination
alors je vais tenter je pense que le
défi est facile à relever d'être un peu
plus courte que notre collègue max
brisson mais plus facile mais parce
qu'il a déjà posé beaucoup de questions
que j'avais évité de reposer alors comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président
nous avons travaillé avec max brisson et
marie pierre monnier sur un bilan des
mesures éducatives du quinquennat je
vais citer juste un chiffre 4 % des
professeurs des écoles considéré que
leur métier est valorisée et moins d'un
français sur deux estime que
l'institution scolaire est efficace dans
la transmission des savoirs fondamentaux
donc à partir de cela comment comptez
vous agir et deuxième question nous
avons fait 36 propositions
les avez vous regardé et comptez vous en
retenir quelques unes donc ça c'est déjà
le premier point deuxième point sur la
féminisation des filières scientifiques
j'avais posé une question écrite qui n'a
pas eu de réponse mais comme un certain
nombre de questions écrites cher
alexandra j'ai vu ta communication sur
le sujet puisque forcément il ya eu un
changement de gouvernement donc sur la
féminisation des filières scientifiques
et techniques
donc forcément depuis 2019 les chiffres
chutent est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
depuis la réforme du lycée la part des
filles inscrits en filière mathématiques
et en terminale a chuté de 10 points en
2021 les filles ne représente que 38 6%
des effectifs et donc la question est
simple puisque vous aviez annoncé ne pas
vouloir toucher à certains totems dans
de telles que parcours sup ou la réforme
du bac donc comment comptez vous vous y
prendre pour inverser cette tendance qui
est évidemment très inquiétantes sur les
avais sachets l'école inclusive vous
l'avez dit vous avez déjà en partie
répondu il ya eu des choses de faites
c'est aujourd'hui insuffisant tant à la
fois dans l'organisation du travail dans
la rémunération du travail aidant
également l'attractivité de ces métiers
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut faire qu'est
ce que vous allez faire surtout par
rapport à cela je voudrais aussi vous
alerter sur un travail que mène la
délégation aux droits des femmes depuis
six mois et alexandra à nouveau je cite
et rapporteur avec moi et deux autres
sénatrice sur le sujet sur la
pornographie
alors évidemment il ya un défi c'est
forcément de le dfid d'empêcher tous ces
mineurs d'accéder à ces à ces images
mais il ya un autre défi aussi c'est
d'appliquer la loi et l'éducation à la
sexualité qui est prévu dans la loi et
qui pour l'instant n'est que très peu
mise en oeuvre ou pas du tout ou mal
mise en oeuvre donc comment allez-vous
peut-être où allez vous prendre en
charge mettre en oeuvre c'est trois
séances obligatoires qui seront
forcément un moyen d'infléchir et
d'éduquer ses jeunes générations qui
pour le moment n'ont comme seule
référence à cette éducation à la
sexualité les images pornographiques
qu'il voit très jeune puisque 80 % des
jeunes mineurs de 12 ans ont été
exposées de manière volontaire ou
involontaire à ces images pour nous est
déplacé dans un collège dans région
parisienne nous avons pu constater aussi
que cela a des conséquences désastreuses
et comme mon collègue max brisson a fait
référence à la médecine scolaire et bien
des médecins scolaires sont désormais
interpellé par deux jeunes adolescents
qui entame une liaison ensemble et comme
le garçon parfois excusez moi messieurs
d'un comme seule référence cet
adolescent là les images pornographiques
qu'il voit il reproduit avec sa petite
amie
c'est comportement ces images et ces
actes sexuels qui sont souvent d'une
grande barbarie d'une grande violence
donc éducation à la sexualité quid de
cette éducation totalement inexistante
et puis monsieur le président votre
prédécesseur comme l'a appelé notre
collègue max brisson
parlait de de jean michel blanc car il
avait une doctrine sur la fermeture des
classes ou la fermeture des écoles quel
sera votre doctrine en la matière
puisque vous le savez tous les ans nous
sommes soumis à la nouvelle carte
scolaire et l'aida zen dans nos
départements ont une tâche assez
difficile étant élu de la vendée je suis
particulièrement sensibles et souvent
engagés sur pour maintenir ses classes
dans les communes merci marie pierre
monnier derrière son écran marie-pierre
je vais le mettre où un camion
tout à l'heure vous avez dit on va poser
la question de savoir si vous étiez une
rupture dans la continuité dans moins de
six mois nous allons nous atteler à
l'examen du projet de loi de finances et
au cours du quinquennat précédent les
politiques qui est engagée notamment le
dédoublement des vous avez évoqué assez
par le relèvement de postes déjà
existants
donc mes doubles et la suppression de
postes dans le secondaire et le pc dans
plfr les prédications 2-0 postes dans le
premier degré et dans le secondaire dans
un contexte de 7 500 suppressions
d'emplois dans le second degré de 2018 à
donc qu'allez vous faire parce qu'on
peut légitimement s'interroger le
contexte budgétaire contraire nous
connaissons et pour le financement
particulier de deux mesures annoncées
comme la les valorisations prévu je
crois que c'est à peu près 6 milliards
d'euros
la généralisation de l'expérimentation
des écoles de futures c'est à peu près
deux milliards ça fait 8 milliards le
budget précédent était de
66,7 cia est ce que vous avez déjà
commencé à plaider la cause du budget de
l'éducation nationale auprès des
ministres du budget éventuellement
président de la république ces mesures
suffiront elles à moyens constants pour
lui assure national au détriment par
exemple de poste
juste vous revient de minutes sur ce
qu'a dit ma collègue annick bio j'avais
interrogé plusieurs fois ministres
précédents sur le manque de deux heures
dédiées à l'éducation d'excès sexualité
voilà qui m'avait dit et on avait des
pans du tueur une mission qui allait se
faire pour faire un état des lieux
est-ce que c'est dans vos projets
je reviens sur
ip à compter sur eux parce que je crois
que c'est un rapport de même qu'il a dit
quand on voit les 4000 postes n'ont pas
été pourvus à l'occasion du compte
organiser en 22 sur un total de 27 lille
332 ouvert et bien franchement c'est
vraiment l'avenir de l'école même qui
est allongée et se pose la question n'a
évoqué la rémunération je poserai juste
une question
là dessus vous parlez beaucoup de jeux
pas une aide pour les nouveaux nouveau
en c1 mais de placer votre approche pour
les enseignantes et enseignants qui sont
en milieu et fin de carrière et
indépendamment de la revalorisation il
l'activité qui est des métiers
enseignants qui sont vraiment qu'est
vraiment à trouver nous avons testé
plusieurs fois dans le cadre du rapport
bilan des mesures éducatives du
quinquennat nous avons mené mes
collègues max brisson et les billes ont
proposé des tas de solutions concrètes
annick vous a demandé si vous allez
reprendre vraiment si les deux
contextes la part de l'enseignant est
trop souvent dévalorisé et où le manque
d'accompagnement par le chef
d'établissement et la hiérarchie
académique est une problématique
récurrente nous avait un peu comme
préconisé la défense systématique par
leur hiérarchie dans de toute remise en
cause de l'autorité non
est ce que c'est votre l'autre point de
vue est ce que vous le mettre en place
concernant la formation des enseignants
nous allons également proposer des pis
que ce soit sur la formation initiale
[Musique]
d'intérêt
labellisation dès la licence parcours
d'études permettant de préparer les
enseignements
une formation continue
de ton fils vraiment sont à l'étude
aujourd'hui sinon quelles sont les
alternatives concrètes que vous proposez
une fable du futur nous avait indiqué
que le projet d école futur nice et à
marseille seraient généralisées alessi
de concertation menée à l'automne est-ce
que vous pouvez d'ores et déjà vous sur
la lancée de cette expérimentation
nombreux postes pourvus dans le cadre du
recrutement particulier que j'ai
consommé sur l'anglais robert globale
prévue autour qualitatif des équipes
concernées
électorale et de transformation des
places est bienvenue concernant le
recrutement dans ce cas spécifiquement
quels seront les critères arrêtés dans
le cadre de la généralisation de
l'expérimentation quand il porte à
chaque équipe de recrutement local ou
dif définis quand les critères globaux
l'ensemble du territoire je reviendrai
pas sur pénurie les jo alors ces recours
bancaires
cachés
a parlé d'une
société en charge
de la mission qui avait été voté et
apparemment ça suffisait d' hier son
niveau d'étude pour faire des
mathématiques des additions et des
soustractions en saisir donc j'espère
cette vigilance sur les compétences
merci alors en vous demandant d'être le
plus rapide possible parce que chacun a
envie de s'exprimer sur un sujet qui
nous tient tous à coeur mais il ya le
souci aussi de laisser un peu de temps
de parole aux autres céline brulin et
ensuite thomas dessus
merci président bonjour monsieur le
ministre je voudrais revenir aussi sur
comme mes collègues sur la grave crise
de recrutement que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et en écho à ce que vient de
dire marie pierre monnier nous sommes un
peu plus inquiet que vous ne semblez
l'être sur les recrutements qui sont en
train de s'opérer il ya évidemment des
mesures d'urgence à prendre
pour que chaque classe et un enseignant
à la rentrée mais il faut être
extrêmement vigilant sur le niveau la
qualité et la compétence de ses
enseignants et puis répondre à la
pénurie ce n'est pas y répondre pour la
rentrée qui vient c'est y répondre dans
la durée et pourquoi sur la base du
recrutement de contractuels auquel nous
sommes contraints aujourd'hui ne
réfléchirai ton pas à des systèmes de
pré recrutement qui ferait que des gens
qui sont peut-être entrer de manière
contractuelle dans l'éducation puisse y
former et y rester sur les rémunérations
qui sont quand même très très lié à
cette crise de recrutement
plusieurs collègues l'ont évoqué là
aussi
il semblerait de plus en plus que cette
évolution de rémunération des
enseignants soient liés à de nouvelles
tâches ou à de nouvelles orientations
qu'il prendrait vous avez je crois vous
même évoqué à l'instant
leur appétence à l'innovation qui
pourrait être un critère permettant d'
une meilleure revalorisation est ce que
vous pouvez préciser cela je voudrais
revenir également sur le manque de
postes dont nous souffrons en
particulier du fait des dédoublements de
classes
en rep et en raid plus
12200 ça a été rappelé en début de cette
audition par le président la faune en
sachant que tous les départements n'ont
encore pas rempli les objectifs qui
étaient pourtant ceux du précédent
quinquennat puisque dans le mien celui
de la seine maritime par exemple tous
les toutes les grandes sections ne sont
pas encore des doublés à l'heure
actuelle et
toutes les classes dans les autres
secteurs ne sont pas aujourd'hui à 24
élèves
quel est votre regard sur l'école en
milieu rural
beaucoup de maires sont très attachés à
l'existence d'une école dans leur
commune et moi je trouve que c'est une
excellente chose que nos élus locaux
soient attachés à la présence de l'école
dans la république dans leur commune
mais je vois des velléités des services
de l'état dans nos départements ou des
services académiques de construire c'est
une sorte d'école idéal qui rayent du cp
au cm2 et qui duplique ray comme ça et
tout ce qu'ils ne répondraient pas à une
école qui va du cp au cm2 n'aurait plus
le droit de cité quel est votre regard
là-dessus
deux dernières questions très rapide
monsieur le président pourquoi acceptez
vous monsieur le ministre que
l'enseignement professionnel soit sorti
du ministère de l'éducation nationale ou
en tout cas à moitié sorti si j'en crois
l'organisation actuelle ne considérez
vous pas que former nos futurs citoyens
c'est assurément les former à des
métiers d'avenir mais c'est aussi former
des citoyens et c'est aussi permettre y
compris aux travailleurs de pouvoir
changer au long de leur carrière ce qui
nécessite un haut niveau de
qualification et enfin je voudrais
revenir aussi sur les aes h leur
formation ou plutôt leur manque de
formation et leur rémunération qui
restent indécentes quelles sont les
mesures que vous envisagez pour répondre
à leur détresse merci pas dessus merci
monsieur le président est monsieur le
ministre toutes mes félicitations pour
votre nomination - contrairement à
d'autres j'attendais une rupture avec
les années de votre précédent votre
prédécesseur monsieur blanc caire vous
avez commencé à décrire une inflexion
dont taxes on peut déjà espérer que vous
serez moins obsédés par les lubies de
mes collègues de droite concernant le
walkie semoule l'islamo gauchisme et
donc je suis plutôt satisfait que vous
pencher plus sérieusement sur les
enseignements des questions
d'environnement qui sont bien plus
prioritaires à mon sens et dans la
méthode on commence à voir une inflexion
et une différence avec votre
prédécesseur puisque vous avez annoncé
aujourd'hui les protocoles sanitaires
bien en amont de la rentrée aux
syndicats ça nous change des annonces la
veille de la rentrée dans des
destinations exotiques
mais vous arrivez dans une période de
grande défiance des équipes pédagogiques
vis-à-vis de votre ministère et cette
défiance elle s'explique assez par le
décalage entre la parole de monsieur
blanc caire et la réalité du terrain et
je vais reprendre comme mes collègues la
question des ave sage puisque sur cette
question le ministre blanc caire faisait
preuve d'une forme d'autosatisfaction en
décalage avec le terrain il se
satisfaisait du recrutement de milliers
d eux s achètent et on pouvait s'en
réjouir aussi mais la question de leur
statut et leur précarité était tellement
prégnante était pesé tellement sur leur
travail que que les parents eux mêmes
s'en plaigne s en plaignent toujours
d'ailleurs et donc je rejoins les
questions sur qu'est-ce que sur la façon
dont vous pouvez envisager leur
déprécarisation et la protection de leur
emploi et sur une autre question sur
l'école du futur moi j'aimerais en avoir
plus de précisions sur sa mise en oeuvre
et notamment sur ce que vous appelez
l'autonomie raisonnable des
établissements puisque se profile en
filigrane de cette autonomie peut être
une rupture de l'égalité républicaine et
comme nous pensons comme vous que la
république se met et ses principes
doivent s'exercer en actes nous
aimerions savoir quelles sont les
garanties pour que cette école de fille
tu du futur ne figure pas le principe
d'égalité républicaine
j'ai une dernière question puisque max
pression ne l'a pas évoquée mais sur les
langues régionales
sur le las la france vient d'être prise
par l'onu dans le traitement des langues
régionales se sent territoire notamment
concernant la décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui a censuré la loi
molac et donc nous aimerions connaître
votre positionnement sur l'enseignement
de ces langues régionales et comment
vous comptez améliorer leur enseignement
je vous remercie
et enfin pour terminer les intervenants
fin groupe bernard fialaire et samantha
casse bonne
mesure
le ministre merci de l'attention que
vous portez et qui va d'ailleurs dans le
sens de la déclaration de la première
ministre qui dit qu elle ne conçoit pas
la république sans senna nous ils
particulièrement le groupe rdse on
pressent pas la république non plus sans
la priorité serait celle de l'éducation
nationale dans l'engagement de notre
société
ça pour assurer l'égalité des chances
qui est bien quand même la priorité à
laquelle on doit être puis de façon
peut-être aussi plus pragmatique dire
qu'un pays dont la richesse et ses
ressources humaines nos autres
ressources et bien ne pas investir dans
nos ressources humaines ce serait une
faute pour la société alors le président
de la république pendant sa campagne
électorale a parlé de mettre autour de
la table justement pour traiter
l'éducation nationale l'ensemble des
collectivités avec l'éducation nationale
l'état et je crois aussi qu'il faut on
peut pas se gargariser sans cesse de
termes comme l'humanisme et pas
l'appliquer l'humaniste et met l'humain
au centre et dans l'éducation nationale
c'est l'enfant au centre au centre des
trois mondes dans lesquels ils vivent
c'est l'école la rue et la famille et on
voit bien qu'il ya un cloisonnement
kiné et qui est préjudiciable
justement sur l'épanouissement des
enfants alors il faut que les
collectivités locales soient associés
les communes parce qu'on a bien vu que
le périscolaire la façon dont on a
transféré le périscolaire a été
peut-être mal vécu mal appréhendé aussi
par les communes et qu'on a
on n'a pas refaire et peut être donner
des moyens pour que les règles qui se
passe dans la rue avec la prise en
charge même d'ailleurs des des
éducateurs de rue et bien n'est pas des
messages différent de celui par exemple
des surveillants dans les établissements
scolaires mais qu'on est bien les mêmes
règles et que plutôt que recréer encore
des usines à gaz de rencontrer bien que
des gens puissent s'y glisser la
deuxième chose c'est qu'ils aient abordé
c'est le problème de la santé et même
d'ailleurs la dimension sociale qui va
autour des enfants les départements
l'ont avec la pmi c'est arrivé jusque
oscillant
les la santé scolaire la scolarité ce
n'est pas une maladie le dépistage
des handicaps des choses sert aussi bien
dans la rue dans la famille qu'à l'école
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi simplifié
et donner un chef de file qui puisse le
faire et avoir sa place enfin pour ce
qui est de l'orientation c'est que les
régions peuvent le faire et il faut que
chacun puisse se sentir bien dans ses
relations avec l'éducation nationale
nous menons actuellement 20 a terminé
une mission d'information sur la
délinquance des mineurs avec c'est
inespéré nier et puis les collègues de
la commission des lois où on voit que
dans tous les dispositifs il lorsqu'il
faut coopérer travailler avec
l'éducation nationale il ya une lourdeur
alors je vous passe aussi tous les
sigles tous les qui sont mes
caricaturaux un vraiment c'est c'est une
ya de quoi en faire un roman qui serait
drôle si c'était pas dramatique il faut
absolument venir alors on attend l'école
primaire apporte vraiment les savoirs
fondamentaux lire écrire compter
il ya un problème à avoir aussi sur les
le secondaire puisque les auditions on a
faits montrent que lorsqu'on interroge
des enfants à distance eh bien il garde
pas un très bon souvenir de leur passage
dans les collèges alors c'est certes
peut-être lié aussi à la tranche d'âge à
l'adolescence enfin il faut pas
contribuer à faire de l'adolescence une
maladie ces périodes de la vie de la
jeunesse qui doit être au contraire plus
radieuse et qu'une prise en charge plus
être un petit peu différent enfin les
lycées moi je regrette que dans mon
département on a des initiatives mais
qui viennent quand même que toujours du
privé par exemple pour avec de très
belles réussites d'enfants qui qui font
quatre années de lycée c'est à dire
qu'ils passent un ca fait un bep et un
bac en quatre ans avec des bonnes
réussites et ça c'est toujours des
initiatives hélas qui viennent pas de
l'éducation nationale et on peut en être
un peu
heurté alors on nous parle après du sc
ni qui sera aussi une période de
rattrapage dans la délégation à la
prospective on a reçu on a fait des
auditions qui nous parlait de faire une
année de propédeutique à la fin des
études pour combler tous les membres il
suffit peut-être de revoir à ce moment
là à la fois la durée de temps dans dans
les établissements scolaires les
programmes pour qu'on n'ait pas besoin
d'aller remettre des pansements au
contraire pour qu'ils constatent et qui
confirme les manques du parcours naturel
voilà ce que je veux dire samantha
cameron
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je fais un peu quitter le
territoire national le réseau
d'enseignement français à l'étranger
contre 566 établissements à travers le
monde scolarisant 380 2000 élèves 80
écoles homologuées de plus qu'en 2017 ce
réseau comme nous le savons est un
formidable outil d'influencé mais il est
aussi le principal sujet de
préoccupation des familles françaises
qui partent s'installer à l'étranger si
plusieurs avancées ont été obtenues lors
du quinquennat précédent et nous pouvons
que nous en réjouir il reste encore
beaucoup à faire monsieur le ministre
pour atteindre à l'horizon 2030 les
objectifs fixés par le président de la
république qui est l'objectif pardon qui
est de doubler les effectifs de notre
réseau français à l'étranger de garantir
aux familles et aux élèves et aux
équipes pédagogiques le maintien de la
qualité qu'ils sont en droit d'attendre
garantir cette qualité relève en partie
des ressources de votre ministère la
formation des personnels la mise à
disposition des titulaires en
détachement sujet très important
également le retour de l'étranger de ses
personnels et la valorisation de leurs
acquis d'expérience encore trop peu
considérée et pourtant si utiles sur
notre pour notre éducation nationale sur
le territoire national femmes et j'avais
obtenu auprès du ministère des affaires
étrangères suite à de nombreuses alertes
une réunion au quai d'orsay dont dépend
l'agencé enseignement français à
l'étranger elle réunissait le secrétaire
général du quai et un grand nombre d
acteurs et opérateurs de ce réseau
parmi eux les membres de votre ministère
en charge de ce sujet à l'issue de cette
concertation était alors annoncé par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale et
des affaires étrangères les deux
ministères de tutelle d'offrir dès la
rentrée une grande consultation mettant
sur la table en sincérité les nombreux
points urgent est incontournable à
traiter car sans cela nous risquons de
devoir revoir les ambitions du président
à la baisse mais plus regrettable encore
nous risquons de dévaluer ce modèle qui
aujourd'hui fait notre fierté et c'est
l'ancien proviseur jusqu'en 2017 qui
vous parle ainsi que le parent d'élève
que je suis encore au sein de ce réseau
alors monsieur le ministre pourriez vous
nous en dire plus nous en ferons pardon
pourriez vous nous dire si votre
ministre ce sera plus que jamais aux
côtés de l'enseignement français à
l'étranger qui accueille je le répète
aujourd'hui 380 mille élèves dont un
tiers de français et deux tiers de
nationalité étrangère à peu près 150
nationalités
voilà merci monsieur le ministre j'ai
ministre je vous laisse y répondre à
cette série déjà abondante de cliff oui
merci merci mesdames et messieurs je
j'ai l'embarras du choix
et je ne suis pas certain de pouvoir
répondre en totalité à toutes vos
questions je vais essayer de l'aider
d'y répondre par par bloc aussi bien que
possible et pardonner si je ne peux pas
creuser autant que vous l'auriez
souhaité je vais commencer par cette
question du métier d'enseignant de
professeurs jeu se trouve que je suis
professeur
cela me touche et concernent
particulièrement qui est une question
que vous avez souligné à la fois du
point de vue des rémunérations ce sur
quoi nous travaillons c'est une
rémunération
des hausses de rémunération à la fois je
dirais une socle pour tous les
enseignants et puis avec une partie
conditionné une partie non conditionnés
et une partie conditionné mais il est
évident que nous devons répondre au
problème d'attractivité dont je parlais
par des hausses de rémunération à 1800
euros
à bac + 5 dans un marché de l'emploi
tendu il est clair que on a du mal et
c'est parfaitement entendent abl nous
avons du mal à recruter donc cette
question là elle est tout à fait
importante mais elle ne recouvre pas
tous delà de la revalorisation de la
requalification du métier d'enseignant
il ya aussi d'autres enjeux qui sont des
enjeux de déroulement de carrière
il y a des avec des trajectoires de
carrière qui ne sont plus aussi linéaire
que par le passé il ya des des personnes
qui entrent dans l'enseignement après
une première carrière dans un autre
secteur il y à des personnes qui
souhaitent qu'ils quittent
l'enseignement il faut réfléchir à des
itinéraires moins linéaire que par le
passé il y a également la question à
propos des rémunérations pardon des
milieux de carrière il est
l'une d'entre vous excusez moi a cité
cette question là il lorsque l'on parle
de hausse de rémunération ce n'est pas
simplement pour les entrées de carrière
mais aussi pour les milieux de carrière
qui sont plats vous avez des milieux de
carrière extrêmement plat sur 12 ou 15
ans avec quasiment pas de hausses de
rémunérations et puis simplement une
hausse de rémunération dans les toutes
dernières années de la carrière et c'est
évidemment quelque chose auquel nous
sommes tout à fait sensible
il a également enfin des questions
relatives au statut des professeurs je
suis frappé par la la le fait que des
parents d'élèves heureusement pas tous
mais s'adresse de façon parfois tout à
fait
déplorable aux enseignants avec
du mépris avec parfois des gestes qui
sont hélas des gestes violents donc nous
devons être aussi très attentifs à allah
au statut social et à la valorisation
des enseignants un point sur les écoles
rurales en effet alors les fermetures
d'écoles sont soumises à l'approbation
des maires je le rappelle mais nous
sommes mais pas les fermetures de
classes en effet et nous sommes dans un
contexte qui est un contexte de baisse
démographique qui est accentuée nous
perdons soixante sept mille élèves entre
la rentrée 2021 et la rentrée 2022 mais
nous ne prenons pas nous ne répercutons
pas la baisse démographique
intégralement nous répercutons environ
la moitié de cette baisse démographique
et nous prenons en charge en quelque
sorte la l'autre moitié de la baisse
démographique ce qui entraîne à une
amélioration du ratio élèves professeurs
mais il faut reconnaître qu'il ya des
fermetures de classes nous sommes
attentifs au fait que dans certaines
régions dans certains territoires
l'école est un des rares services
publics et donc on ne peut pas traiter à
égalité
toutes les situations nous sommes
attentifs aux situations locales et il
arrive il est tout à fait fréquents
comme j'ai pu le voir que nous
maintenions en activité des classes
alors même que selon des critères
stricts elle ne devrait pas être
maintenue en activité nous avons aussi
de la souplesse dans la manière dont
nous apprécions les choses et je reçois
de votre part ainsi que de la part de
très nombreux élus et parlementaires
côté assemblée nationale des demandes
relatives à la fermeture des classes
auxquelles nous prêtons toujours une
très grande attention sur l'école
maternelle je crois monsieur le sénateur
brisson que c'est vous qui m'avez
vielles
sollicité de ce côté là il est certain
que nous nous penchons sur les écoles
maternelles de même que sur les collèges
qui ont été un peu qu'ils n'ont pas fait
l'objet d'une attention très forte ces
dernières années pour des raisons qui
s'explique parfaitement et donc nous
engageons en effet une réflexion sur les
écoles maternelles sur la part un plan
maternelle que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'annoncer lors du congrès des
enseignants d'écoles maternelles qui se
tenait à périgueux la semaine dernière
plan de formation des enseignants
il y à une vitalité pédagogique qui est
tout à fait remarquable du côté des
écoles maternelles il ya également une
réflexion engagée à propos des petites
sections et des moyennes sections donc
nous sommes au travail
via le plan maternelle pour avancer sur
ce sujet qui me semble en effet tout à
fait important je voudrais aussi
rebondir sur la question de l'éducation
à la sexualité
c'est une question tout à fait essentiel
que j'ai d'ailleurs mentionné dans la
circulaire de rentrée et nous allons
avancer sur cette question un rapport a
été écrit en 2001 mais à ma connaissance
il n'a pas été publié donc nous devons
et je fait de cette question une
question tout à fait importante pour les
raisons que vous avez dit madame la
sénatrice et pour plein d'autres raisons
qui sont liées à l'épanouissement
personnel mais qui sont liées aussi à la
prévention des violences sexuelles et
sexistes c'est aussi un une manière
d'agir de ce côté là et donc je suis
très sensible à au point que vous avez
soulevé ainsi que l'un ou l'une de vos
collègues je voudrais dire qu'elle
dirait mots à propos de l'école du futur
puisque plusieurs personnes sont
intervenues à ce sujet le plus alors
pour l'instant cette ces projets
marseillais concerne 59 écoles dont les
projets ont été sélectionnés
ces écoles bénéficient d'un soutien
financier pour mettre en oeuvre ses
projets et le président de la république
a visité le 2 juin dernier l'une de ces
écoles qui met en oeuvre un laboratoire
de mathématiques dans une perspective
dans la perspective d'ailleurs
collective que j'indiquais tout à
l'heure où les mathématiques sont
enseignés de façon beaucoup plus comment
dirais-je pratique et même ludique par
certains égards que l' approche plus
théorique et abstraite qui a été
longtemps celle de l'enseignement des
mathématiques en france suivant en cela
d'ailleurs des enseignements que l'on
peut tirer des pays qui réussissent très
bien
dans les mathématiques non pas dans la
formation d'une élite mathématiques la
france est au premier plan à ce sujet
mais dans je dirais le niveau
mathématique moyen de la population et
pour répondre à un des points qui était
celui du sénateur brisson je crois est
bien l'une des leçons que l'on peut
retirer des expériences internationales
c'est justement une approche plus plus
pratique et donc un travail sur la
pédagogie que messieurs villani et aux
lotions d'ailleurs proposé dans un
rapport qu'ils ont écrit à ce sujet donc
il ne s'agit pas d'ajouter des heures
supplémentaires sans réfléchir à la
pédagogie il nous faut absolument
réfléchir la pédagogie à propos des
savoirs fondamentaux et notamment de la
question
importante des mathématiques le niveau
en mathématiques moyens je dirais est
préoccupant et les mathématiques font
partie des savoirs jeudi courant des
savoirs ordinaire pour tous les citoyens
et toutes les citoyennes
je reviens à l'école du futur 59 projets
il démarre il on en est quand même au
début dé de ses projets à marseille que
nous suivons très attentivement et donc
nous voulons généraliser quand on parle
de généralisation on nous parle on ne
passe pas de 59 écoles à toutes les
écoles de france mais on monte en
puissance en allant au delà de marseille
du côté de d'école du côté
d'établissements qui seront
partants pour
construire un projet pédagogique mettant
en valeur le travail collectif mettant
en valeur aussi les projets pédagogiques
parfois fondées sur des projets
d'établissements existants comme c'est
le cas à marseille afin de
d'améliorer les conditions
d'enseignement mais surtout évidemment
les résultats car ces projets
s'accompagne d'une évaluation qui n'a
pas pour but de classer les
établissements entre eux ni même de
jouer des faits de concurrence mais qui
a objectif de vérifier et de mesurer la
progression des élèves à cet égard
j'insiste sur l'importance des
évaluations qui nous permettent
d'affiner de comprendre et de mesurer et
d'adapter également nos politiques
éducatives elles sont tout à fait
essentiel et nous allons
vers une accroissement des évaluations
tout en faisant attention à ne pas
entrer dans une logique qui serait une
logique de classement l'école du futur
c'est une opportunité qui
doit être réglé y compris d'un point de
vue juridique vous avez fait je crois
monsieur le sénateur brisson allusion à
la personnalité morale des écoles
primaires c'est en effet une des
difficultés juridiques qui se posent il
y as d'autres questions l'autorité
fonctionnelle des directeurs ne me
semble pas devoir être remise en cause à
ce stade on a je crois un bon équilibre
la concertation avec les communautés
éducatives avec les parents d'élèves
avec le parascolaire avec les élus
j'insiste beaucoup sur la concertation
avec les élus locaux pour parvenir à des
changements à des améliorations qui ne
se fasse pas dans une verticalité qui
tombe depuis la rue de grenelle avec
toutes les résistances que cela peut
entraîner et de façon parfois très
légitime mais par le bas si je puis dire
en sollicitant les intelligences en
sollicitant les intelligences
collectives et en faisant ce qui est en
s'appuyant sur ce qui fonctionne et
semble fonctionner de façon tout à fait
passionnante à marseille nous nous
appuyons en effet sur
l'expérience marseillaise sur les
projets marseillais pour avancer un mot
sur les aes h
la question m'a été posée je crois à
deux reprises c'est en effet un sujet de
vie j'ai un point de vigilance on a une
augmentation tout à fait remarquable
c'est cinq dernières années
deux du nombre des lèvres incluant si tu
as besoin particulier en inclus dans les
écoles ordinaires je dirais on est passé
de 300 milles à 400 milles avec un
nombre d'arrivées sache qui a crû de
façon également très importante on est
aux alentours de 120 milles à eux sache
aujourd'hui ce qui pose un certain
nombre de difficultés y compris je ne
vous le cache pas des difficultés
budgétaires
puisque la croissance du nombre
d'arrivées sage pèse a un effet sur nous
sur notre budget comme nous avons pu en
échanger sur ce point avec madame
darrieussecq et monsieur combes hier
donc il faut réfléchir sur les besoins
particuliers et sur la meilleure manière
de répondre à ses besoins particuliers
qui ne passe pas nécessairement par dms
h et il faut en effet réfléchir à leur
rémunération
il ya un processus de céder isation des
ash environ 20% sont aujourd'hui en cdi
zay
mais il y à bien cette question des 24
heures
ddos h 24 heures hebdomadaires qui
fait que les rémunérations ne sont pas
satisfaisantes le président de la
république a évoqué la possibilité de 35
heures hebdomadaires pour les aes h et
c'est dans ce sens là que nous
travaillons pour sécuriser les carrières
d'alès h et pour en même temps faire de
telle sorte que budgétairement la
trajectoire soit soutenable parce que
pour l'instant on est à 2 3 milliards du
côté des ash c'est une somme importante
et qui est en croissance et donc nous
nous pencherons également
sur cette cette dimension là
quand nous réfléchissons sur le métier
des ash je voudrais encore si je ne sais
pas si monsieur le président j'ai encore
un peu de temps pour avancer sur
certaines sur certaines questions sur
l'enseignement professionnel je voudrais
rassurer je ne sais plus qui m'a
interrogé pardonnez moi pardon c'est
cela
pardonnez moi madame la sénatrice
sur l'enseignement professionnel il est
bien évident que l'enseignement
professionnel reste dans le giron du
ministère de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse je veux dire les lycées
professionnels restent dans notre giron
mais il y a une ministre délégué madame
carole grandjean ministre délégué à la
formation professionnelle et au lycée
professionnel qui est à cheval si j'ose
dire sur ce ministère et le ministère du
travail cette transversalité un peu
comme dans le cas de madame elle a écrit
vise au fond a
favorisé la question de l'insertion de
nos jeunes dans les stages les stages se
font en milieu professionnel bien
entendu mais le mit le ministère de
l'éducation nationale garde la main sur
l'enseignement sur tout ce qui relève de
l'enseignement professionnel des savoirs
fondamentaux de l'éducation au métier
mais aussi à la citoyenneté
j'insiste sur ce point nous nous visons
à une meilleure efficacité à une
meilleure insertion sur le marché du
travail et donc à de meilleurs à une
intensification des relations entre les
lycées professionnels et le monde du
travail en général c'est ce que j'ai pu
voir lors d'un déplacement dans le jura
tout à fait instructif il y a quelques
semaines mais ça n'est pas une manière
de sortir surtout pas l'enseignement
professionnel du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
sur les questions
d'environnement
[Musique]
peut-être oui je j'insiste sur la
question du
bâti scolaire qui fait l'objet de nos de
notre vigilance pour les points pour les
raisons que j'ai indiquées et sur le
fait que les processus de rénovation du
bâti scolaire notamment de ce bâti
intermédiaire celui des années 50 60 70
qui résiste mal à la chaleur et qui est
de surcroît très coûteux l'hiver du
point de vue d'un point de vue thermique
que cela ne peut se faire qu'en
concertation avec la première instance
concernés c'est-à-dire la mairie le
département ou la région et j'ai été
très sensible dans les échanges que j'ai
pu avoir avec des mères ou bien encore
avec le président des départements de
france ou encore avec
les régions avec monsieur bono qui
s'occupe plus particulièrement des
questions d'éducation à leurs intérêts
et leur souhait de travailler en
concertation avec nous sur ce sujet
les jardins d'enfants je le mentionne au
passage c'est un point en effet tout à
fait
important qui a souffert de façon
indirecte de la loi par ailleurs tout à
fait bénéfique sur la scolarisation des
enfants à partir de 3 ans de la loi de
2019 j'en ai parlé aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avec madame anne hidalgo qui
est concerné par les jardins d'enfants
et j'ai été alerté sur ce sujet par
plusieurs élus et plusieurs membres du
gouvernement et donc nous devons trouver
une solution
juridique pour essayer de faire de telle
sorte que les jardins d'enfants
continuent leur leurs activités jeux
c'est un point auquel je suis sensible
monsieur le sénateur il nous faut
trouver un chemin pour cela
qui qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
soutenables mais c'est une question que
je note
je ne sais pas il ya d'autres questions
là les langues régionales d'accord qui
consistait pas la plus facile non c'est
ça vous avez raison qui concerne
actuellement un demi million d'élèves je
crois qu'il ya cinq cent vingt mille
élèves et deux des langues
supplémentaires 5 langues se sont
ajoutés donc le total est tout à fait
notable on est à dix sept langues
régionales
si ma mémoire est bonne de ce côté-là et
un certain nombre de questions se posent
du côté de l'enseignement des langues
régionales
côté du pays basque qui vous est cher
monsieur le sénateur nous avons
répondu à une interpellation
très républicaine par ailleurs même si
elle était un peu vigoureuse je crois
qu'ils nous étaient faites du côté de
bayonne quant aux épreuves du brevet et
donc nous avons répondu du côté du
ministère en indiquant qu' il fallait
échangé à ce sujet que nous allons
prendre le temps d'échanger mais que
nous ne répondions pas dans l'immédiat à
à une question qui est une question très
sérieuse qui doit être examiné bien au
delà du de ce ministère dans l'inter
gouvernants gouvernementalité donc je
suis très attentif et pour vous dire les
choses très franchement j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire d'ailleurs il y a
quelques jours je prête personnellement
une oreille très
favorable en tout cas je n'ai pas de
problème de difficulté de principe
quant aux langues régionales je
les questions de bilinguisme et les
questions d'expression linguistique
j'y suis personnellement sensible mais
évidemment on doit trouver le bon chemin
les bons équilibres et donc ce que je
vous propose c'est d'échanger à ce sujet
tant du côté du pays basque que du côté
d'autres régions concernées je suis tout
à fait disposé à échanger je ne suis pas
le seul interlocuteur sur ces questions
comme vous pouvez le deviner
pardon je voulais dire un mot aussi sur
les lycées français à l'étranger
vous avez madame la sénatrice
tout à fait raison de
m'interpeller à ce sujet pour dire
d'abord que nous ne sommes que c'est
d'abord le ministère des affaires
étrangères mais nous avons une mission
importante qui est celle de la
certification des établissements pour
nous assurer que les établissements
français à l'étranger sont s'inscrivent
dans les programmes du ministère de
l'éducation nationale et puis le
détachement des enseignants ce qui est
également une mission importante et donc
ce que je peux vous dire à ce stade et
nous allons travailler en bonne
intelligence avec madame la ministre des
affaires étrangères madame colonna c'est
que je suis moi aussi enfin très
attentifs et très sensible à la présence
de ces établissements à leur bonne santé
à tous égards temps il compte pour la
diffusion du français pour la
francophonie puis là le rayonnement de
la à l'étranger c'est une question
absolument essentiel et je serais
heureux d'échanger plus avant avec vous
en lien avec le ministère des affaires
étrangères qui est le principal
opérateur mais nous sommes au ministère
de l'éducation nationale très les
attentifs moi qui ai longtemps vécu
aussi à l'étranger qui connaît beaucoup
de lycées français à l'étranger un peu
partout dans le monde vous trouverez en
moi un l interlocuteur bienveillant et
attentif à ce que je peux vous dire à ce
stade alors vous êtes encore nombreux à
vouloir poser des questions aux
ministres vraiment d'être le plus bref
possible et je vous propose ce qui est
une façon de dire vous n'avez pas le
choix de commencer par nos collègues de
province parce qu'il ya des des avions
ou des trains et nos collègues
franciliens s'ils sont d'accord
attendront dans une deuxième partie
allez on va commencer donc alexandra
mansiaux fontain cédric filiale sabine
van heghe
olivier paccaud
et sabine drexler
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues merci pour
vos propos monsieur le ministre je suis
là sur votre gauche non on va toujours
ce parti jeu
merci pour vos propos je disais à
l'instant monsieur le ministre même si
vous n'avez pas aborder un sujet ô
combien important pour nos d auneau néo
bachelier en ce moment il s'agit de
parcours sup
il s'appelle notamment jonathan ses 25
ans ont reçu une réponse favorable
en revanche pour enguerrand excellente
élève au lycée militaire de saint-cyr
tous ces voeux ont été refusées et puis
il ya le ciel pour dénoncer les failles
du système de sélection elle a envoyé
une recette de cuisine comme lettre de
motivation sont veut lui a été acceptée
alors face à ces trois exemples que
répondre aux dizaines de milliers de
candidats encore 100 propositions
d'admission depuis ses débuts en 2018 en
tout cas elle ne s'est pas passé une
année sans que son fonctionnement nettes
étaient critiquées critères de sélection
absurde algorithmes opaque et puis
absence totale de prise en compte des
autres éléments que les notes le cas de
l'ue ciel le prouver pu permettez moi
d'ajouter qu'en tant que mère de famille
l'utilisation de cette plate forme est
très complexe pour un lycéen je ne suis
pas certaine qu'il y ait cette fameuse
égalé des chances argument majeur
portant de cette application nous sommes
donc en 2022 il n'est pas tolérable
locaux tant d'étudiants sont ainsi
privés de la chance qu'offre la poursuit
des études dans l'enseignement supérieur
mon intervention n'a pas pour but de
tirer à boulet rouge sans fondement
aucun sur parcours sup mais bien sûr de
vous emmener à nous expliquer ces
défaillances et surtout à nous exposer
les voies d'amélioration auquel vous
avez je n'en doute pas pensé je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voulais en profiter pour
saluer votre directeur de cabinet
monsieur armée qui qui a dû
s'en aller
j'ai deux questions la première
concernant les avez ça je vous l'avais
abordée sur le plan du statut mais moi
j'aimerais pouvoir l'aborder sur le
planche de l'inclusion et d'aider des
personnes fin des enfants en situation
de handicap qui est quand même nous
semble-t-il l'objectif principal de ces
mesures et là vous avez je crois que
nous avons devant nous une bombe à
retardement qui n'est pas un feu
d'artifice
quiris de s'amorcer dès la rentrée
scolaire comme vous le savez votre
prédécesseur a allumé la mèche
finalement on saisissant le conseil
d'état et une décision du 20 novembre
2020 a modifié le
l'intervention des avs h sur le temps
périscolaire
et sur le temps scolaire ou le conseil
d'état un signal aujourd'hui que le
temps périscolaire donc l'accompagnement
des enfants en situation d'handicap sur
sedan et notamment le temps méridien
relèvent des collectivités locales
dont acte même si on pourrait
s'interroger de ce découpage de
l'inclusion par par période plutôt que
d'avoir un suivi de l'enfant dans sa
dent dans son intégralité on parle
beaucoup d'éducation globale depuis la
stratégie de lisbonne que j'ai remis sa
délégation nationale habituellement mais
on a maintenant un problème de fond le
conseil d'état a relevé trois
propositions pour se sortir de cette
situation monsieur blanc caire lord
interrogations de certains d'entre nous
ont ouvert de france avait rappelé ses
trois propositions c'était dire soit la
commune embauche son propre personnel
soit l embauche de personnels de
l'éducation nationale en termes de cumul
d'emplois soit il y aura des mises à
disposition de personnel embauché est
donc formé et ses parts par le ministère
et qui seront juste compenser
financièrement par les collectivités on
n'est pas là pour contester la question
du coup vous l'avez dit mais je
comprends mieux depuis tout à l'heure et
quel était l'objectif de cette saisie du
conseil d'état une question financière
probablement
sauf que aujourd'hui cette troisième
solution qui était la mise à disposition
proposée par le conseil d'état affirmer
comme la solution par par votre
prédécesseur n'est pas mise en place
nulle part à ma connaissance nulle part
j'ai pas trouvé un exemple d'un
département qui acceptaient de la mise
en place malgré les consignes données
par le ministre
donc votre prédécesseur donc de deux
choses l'une soit l'administration au
niveau local répond à des règles d'un
ami répond plus
à sa hiérarchie première hypothèse soit
vous avez
essayé d'atténuer les choses dans le
discours public mais mais mais ça ne
fonctionne pas donc seul la situation d
aide d un message
que pouvez vous nous dire et notamment
pouvez-vous nous nous rassurer sur la
possibilité de mettre en place ces
nouvelles conventions de mise à
disposition dès la rentrée scolaire je
vous dis on a en fait face à une bombe à
retardement g20 une deuxième question
mais je pense qu'il faut je peux la
faire très rapidement deuxième question
c'est sur les questions de jeunesse et
de vie associative
vous êtes commissaire la pédagogie ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer comment
ça va s'organiser quel va être le
devenir de la james va par exemple et de
la vie associative puisqu'on a
maintenant une secrétaire d'état en
charge de la vie associative qui est
rattachée directement au premier
ministre donc qui qui va avoir la
tutelle de cette direction les fonds de
vie associative et de cédric pardon je
jette un terreau mais la vie associative
n'est pas
voilà c'était c'est ma question elle
l'était je vous répondrais constants
elles étaient jusqu'à présent en partie
notamment l'éducation populaire et la
direction de la jeunesse et de la vie
associative
ça ne s'appelait comme ça au sein du
ministère qui va avoir la tutelle sur ce
monsieur sur cette vie associative le
fonds le fonds départemental vie
associative dépendait de ce ministère
qui vont en avoir la tutelle et
notamment sur le lait c'est lui qui
n'était aussi directement dépendant du
ministère jusqu'à présent est maintenant
partagée que me sert désormais est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il y aura aussi un
financement de la part du ministère des
armées du assainies ce que c'est ça
l'objectif comment ça comment les choses
vont s'articuler
sami drexler ils ont merci oui monsieur
le ministre vous présenter le
dédoublement des classes dans les
secteurs dits prioritaires comme un
facteur d'égalité des chances or l'on
sait que la majorité des élèves qui
rencontrent des difficultés lourdes et
persistante est scolarisé hors éducation
prioritaire notamment dans la ruralité
dans des secteurs par ailleurs éloigné
de structure médico psycho pédagogique
qui pourrait être une réponse lorsque
l'école n'est plus en mesure
d'accompagner par des dispositifs
classiques les situations les plus
lourdes qui ont par ailleurs explosé on
le sait avec la crise sanitaires alors
les élus des territoires que nous sommes
constate l'absence de politiques dédiés
aux espaces ruraux en matière de prise
en charge de la difficulté scolaire et
déplore le fait que ceux ci soient
désavantagés par des mesures reposant
sur une perception très urban au centre
et de ses sujets les dispositifs mis en
oeuvre à part l'éducation nationale
devrait à nos yeux s'appliquer partout
sur l'ensemble du territoire puisque le
principe d'égalité reconnus comme une
valeur primordiale du service public de
l'éducation nationale est le marqueur de
notre pacte républicain
alors monsieur le ministre le décrochage
scolaire a un coût social et économique
très important les enjeux sont énormes
quelles mesures comptez-vous mettre en
oeuvre pour accompagner la ruralité sur
ces sujets
olivier paccaud
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre bienvenue au sénat
j'ai une question sur l'inclusion mais
de façon très précise mais avant je je
tiens à revenir un tout petit peu sur
l'éducation prioritaire vous avez un
petit peu parler de la problématique de
la carte vous avez parlé de réflexion
venir on lance une réflexion votre
prédécesseur il ya quatre ans déjà nous
parler de réflexion alors il faut pas
confondre vitesse et précipitation
mais à ce rythme là j'espère que ça va
aboutir un jour parce que comme vient de
le dire sabine draxler ya un véritable
problème avec 70% des chiffres ne sont
pas de moi d'enfants qui devrait être en
zone d'éducation prioritaire qui n'y
sont pas parce que les critères
d'éligibilité sont totalement
ubuesque war baroque et malheureusement
ça n'est pas traitée aujourd'hui je
remarque que le nombre de ministres n'a
pas changé il y en a un seul qui a
disparu c'est le secrétaire d'état à
l'éducation prioritaire je n'en déduis
pas que ce n'est plus une priorité mais
quand même ma question concerne
l'inclusion et plus précisément plus
précisemment l'inclusion des élèves
présentant des troubles du comportement
c'est un sujet qui n'est pas abordée par
l'institution mais je peux vous dire
qu'il est évoqué par de très nombreux
enseignants on se demande si c'est même
pas un sujet tabou au niveau de
l'éducation nationale je parle d'enfants
qui relève de structures adaptées avec
des professionnels formés pour
spécialisés et qui aujourd'hui sont dans
les classes parce qu'à pas de place dans
les structures adaptées sont dans des
classes entre guillemets traditionnels
et même si on peut avoir des fois des
avs et des ash dans beaucoup de cas on à
la création d'un d'une atmosphère
particulièrement négative difficile qui
peut conduire certains enseignants au
bord de la dépression au bord de la
démission et
pardonnez moi de vous le dire mais j'ai
de nombreux exemples en tête de
d'enseignants chevronnés insulter à
longueur de journée frappé à longueur de
journée par des élèves de ce2 cm1
avec une hiérarchie qui ne réagit pas
qui fait une politique de l'autruche
qui va avoir des résultats tout à fait
dramatique pour les enfants concernés
pour les enseignants concernés et pour
les autres élèves de la classe merci de
me répondre monsieur le ministre là on
va passer maintenant aux franciliens
c'est que ceux qui sont derrière leur
écran
céline boulay sp rogner thuan bora
qui gagnent chanterelle qui n'a rien de
franciliens mais j'imagine que tu n'as
pas un avion ce soir donc et puis il
restera alors darcos et puis sabine
burning
merci monsieur le président très
rapidement puisque effectivement j'avais
un certain nombre de questions qui ont
fort bien été posées par l'ensemble de
mes collègues et c'est vrai que quand on
arrive en bout de course finalement on
ne peut qu être rapide puisque on ne
veut pas être redondant la première
d'entre elles évidemment concerné les
difficultés de recrutement et je note
une légère inflexion dans votre discours
monsieur ministre puisqu'il ya quelques
semaines vous disiez qu'il y aurait un
enseignant à la prochaine rentrée devant
chaque porte et maintenant vous dites
que c'est un objectif donc vous partagez
certainement l'inquiétude de notre
commission
le troisième axe des cinq axes de votre
futur ministère c'est effectivement le
bien-être des élèves et vous dit même
que c'est un devoir d'état qui est la
preuve que vous prenez ceci très au
sérieux moi il ya deux sujets qui me
tiennent à coeur qui sont le sujet du
harcèlement et du cyber harcèlement qui
est un problème qui est exponentielle et
dont on voit puisque mon collègue
bernard fialaire a très gentiment fait
référence aux au rapport sur lequel nous
travaillons sur la délinquance juvénile
et la délinquance des mineurs que c'est
un sujet qui est quand même relativement
méconnu des acteurs des différents
acteurs et qui est pas toujours pris à
bras le corps par l'éducation nationale
et qui surtout est le résultat d'un
empilement de mesures et quelquefois on
aurait l'impression que l'un des maîtres
mots de votre prochain ministère devrait
être la simplification et la
rationalisation et d'ailleurs si on en
juge par le rapport de la cour des
comptes qui date de ce matin il me
semble l'éducation nationale est là et
l'inde et est l'un des secteurs enfin
les plus l'une des éducations les plus
chers d'europe pour des résultats qui
somme toute parfois son décevant et donc
il y aurait matière peut-être à
redistribuer les richesses au sein de
l'éducation nationale
j'aurais aimé que vous nous disiez un
petit mot s'il vous plaît nous ne
détaillé l'action des équipes des
valeurs de la république telles que vous
les
avait appelé qui est une des choses que
vous voulez mettre en place et enfin
dernière chose pour faire référence à
petit côté agressif de la remarque de
notre collègue thomas d'haussy tout à
l'heure il me semble qu'il n'ya pas de
question tabou au sein de cette
commission
aucun groupe n'a de l'uby j'aime à le
croire et nous sommes là monsieur
ministre pour mieux vous connaître et si
des questions ont fait polémique dans la
presse ces dernières semaines il est
très bien qu'on puisse vous poser des
questions pour savoir ce qu'il en est et
nous savons tous que l'école de la
république a pu être traversée par des
courants contradictoires ces dernières
années ces derniers mois la presse s'en
est fait l'écho ce qui de notre
commission était là pour auditionner
monsieur urbain et son rapport le savent
très bien et il me semble que les
questions sociétales et philosophie qui
touche les cols sont essentielles et
doivent être au coeur de nos
préoccupations je vous remercie
toi de bourran merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
m'associe évidemment à mes collègues à
l'occasion de votre première audition et
à quelques semaines maintenant dollar et
ma rentrée scolaire pour vous adresser
mes voeux de réussite dans vos nouvelles
fonctions
notre école est notre bien le plus
précieux car c'est le terreau de la
france de demain et les questions sont
nombreuses tant le mal est profond je
vais tenter d'aller à l'essentiel sur
des points très précis que nous sommes
plusieurs à évoquer chacun avec ses
sensibilités
et je voudrais revenir en premier lieu
pour parler du climat scolaire que vient
d'évoquer rapidement mon collègue le
sénateur pas qu aujourd'hui l'autorité
est entre les mains de ceux qui
devraient pourtant en apprendre les
vertus tour en tout temps à la démagogie
au détriment du cadrage la liste des
interdits est aujourd'hui plus longue
dans le camp dans le corps enseignant
que dans le règlement des élèves au
quotidien les enseignants ne dispose
plus de moyens pour faire respecter les
règles et leur autorité pire vous l'avez
rapidement évoqué tout à l'heure les
parents s'immiscer contestent
régulièrement les décisions et les
sanctions prises à l'égard de leurs
enfants
aussi je veux savoir comment vous
comptez rétablir l'autorité bafouer
l'autorité perdu dans les établissements
scolaires
j'en viens mon deuxième point qui a
trait à la prise du savoir et donc aux
piètres au niveau de nos élèves
cela est évoqué rapidement
pas rapidement cela a été évoqué tout à
l'heure les chiffres du pisa 2018 sont
très éloquents puisque il place la
france dans une situation de médiocrité
confondante et nos élèves aujourd'hui
n'évolue pas tous au même rythme et
la question de la médiocrité se pose
peut être aussi par l'uniformisation du
parcours alors qu'aujourd'hui tous les
témoignages convergent pour dire que la
fin du redoublement est une erreur en ne
permettant plus aux établissements
d'adapter le cursus scolaire au niveau
réel de leurs élèves beaucoup d'enfants
se retrouve en sixième sans maîtriser
les fondamentaux voir en terminale avec
des difficultés criantes donc je
voudrais savoir quelle est votre
position sur le rétablissement du
redoublement
concernant la question le thème de la
formation et du recrutement je ne vais
pas développer ça et cela a été
développé largement par mes collègues
simplement je voudrais savoir alors même
qu'un collectif de parents d'élèves
d'île de france engage un recours contre
l'état pour dénoncer l'absence de
remplacements d'enseignants
pour l'année scolaire qui vient de
s'écouler quelles sont les pistes
précises envisagée pour surseoir à ce
besoin sans risquer de présenter à la
rentrée des contractuels inexpérimenté
pouvant partir en cours d'année
ensuite je voudrais revenir sur la
liaison de rurales et les fermetures de
classes
c'est un sujet qui me semble très
important
l'école est souvent le coeur battant de
nos villages et une classe ou un
enseignant c'est aussi le socle d'un
bassin de vie le sort d'une classe de
bouleverser l'équilibré d'une commune or
nos écoles sont victimes d'un système
qui selon moi est archaïque et qui les
emprisonnent souvent dans une situation
de sursis permanent d'insécurité
chronique puisque aujourd'hui chaque
année les maires sont suspendus à une
procédure de révision de carte scolaire
qui s'établit d'octobre à juin voire en
septembre et un nouveau comptage et même
réalisé le jour de la rentrée scolaire
pour certains donc les décisions finales
repose sur des visions à très court
terme
vous avez parlé de souplesse tout à
l'heure mais souvent ces décisions ne
tiennent pas compte des projets
immobiliers prévus dans les communes
même des logements devant être livrés en
cours d'année scolaire ce qui conduit
régulièrement à des situations ubuesques
comme la fermeture d'une classe pour
seulement un ou deux élèves en moins par
rapport au barème est de voir à rouvrir
l'année suivante est ce type de procédé
traduit par ailleurs selon moi un manque
de considération pour tous les acteurs
concernés que ce soit les enseignants
les parents et les élus alors pourquoi
ne pas envisager une procédure qui
prendrait en compte une vision à plus
long terme de la carte scolaire une
carte triennal en somme en permettant
évidemment la possibilité d'ajustement
en cas de changements extrêmes et pour
conclure je voudrais évoquer le point
crucial de la laïcité nous avons appris
qu'une note fouillée du renseignement
territoriale révélé début juin avait
fait état d'une hausse des cas de port
de tenues religieuses dans les
établissements scolaires et pourtant
vous avez décidé de lancer une collecte
de données pour faire remonter un
certain nombre d'informations et avoir
une vision synthétique de la situation
étant donné que vous aviez grâce à cette
note tous les éléments en main pour agir
et sachant que tous les témoignages
émanant des établissements scolaires
corroborent ce constat pourquoi ne pas
vous en tenir à ce document précis qui
émane donc de l'intérieur et du
renseignement territoriale
et pourquoi cette perte de temps en lieu
et place de l'action voilà je vous
remercie de chanterelles
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre en tout cas nous nous nous
ferons pas de procès d'intention bien
évidemment monsieur le ministre nous
avons aucun doute sur le fait que vous
êtes un républicain plutôt honte à
celles et à ceux qui vous font ce faux
procès d'anti républicanisme car comme
vous l'avez très bien rappelé est
républicain c'est justement se battre
contre les inégalités et les
discriminations qui mène notre pays je
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'en cette veille
de fête nationale
deux démos de notre devise républicaine
c'est égalité et fraternité
faudrait juste faire en sorte que ce ne
soit pas des mots creux que ça soit
réellement une réalité c'est ça qui est
fondamental donc nous ne bougerons pas
sûr
/ nous userons que sur les actes au delà
des voeux de bonnes intentions bien
évidemment il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont déjà été abordées il ya peut-être
d'ailleurs un constat mutuel que nous
pouvons faire sur le fait que vous
l'avez vous même dit dans votre propos
liminaire c'est l'écart de plus en plus
importants justement entre les élèves
issus des milieux défavorisés et ceux
issus des classes supérieures vous
l'avez également dit dans votre propos
liminaires et la france est un des pays
qui parvient le moins à vaincre la
reproduction sociale et son corollaire
d'inégalités mais méfions-nous aussi des
discours souvent sur la méritocratie qui
donne l'illusion que nous serions toutes
et tous à égalité comme vous le savez
certainement très bien nous avons pas la
même chance de réussite en fonction de
notre capitale jusqu'à l' et culturelle
de départ notre lieu d'habitation pas la
même chance selon que nous habitions
dans le quartier où nous siégeons ou
dans un quartier défavorisé
donc l'objectif prioritaire d'un
ministre de l'éducation nationale ce
devrait être une lutte implacable jeu
contre ces inégalités et c'est très
propre production sociale qui minent
effectivement notre pays afin de faire
de l'école un réel creuset de
l'émancipation de toutes et tous alors
dans les causes de ces difficultés ça a
déjà été abordé il ya bien sûr la
rémunération mais vous l'avez déjà
répondu les moyens aussi mise à
disposition de nos enseignants mais il
ya aussi vous l'avez également abordé en
partie évidemment
l'importance de faire évoluer les
méthodes éducatives et je vous dis ça
d'autant plus que moi même je suis
parlementaire des français établis hors
de france et il ya d'autres choses qui
se font ailleurs qui fonctionne - et qui
évite cette reproduction sociale nous on
a une méthode ici en france qui est très
scripturale où tout passe par les cris
basé sur des cours magistraux ou la
posture de l'élève est souvent passive
dans des journées qui sont souvent
d'ailleurs trop longue il ya des choses
qui peuvent être inspirante moi j'ai vu
par exemple vous avez cité les modèles
nordiques c'est très juste très juste
d'ailleurs il ya le modèle finlandais
notamment il ya aussi plus proche de
nous on les prend souvent comparatif
pour des questions économiques mais
jamais en matière éducative c'est
l'allemagne
par exemple où il ya moins d'examens
écrit il ya des cours beaucoup moins
longs au moyen de ces 45 minutes il ya
plus d échanges avec les élèves par le
biais de jeux de rôle ou encore la
classe inversée généralisation des
classes de 25 élèves donc ça ça prend
des moyens par contre pour pouvoir le
mettre en place donc c'est pas le tout
de vouloir faire évoluer les choses ça
prend des moyens effectivement et donc
il faudrait pouvoir s'inspirer de ces
choses là mais pour ça il faut une
réelle volonté politique il faut les
moyens qui vont avec vous avez parlé de
l'expérimentation de marseille c'est sûr
que nous on souhaite en savoir un peu
plus dans les détails sur ce qui va être
fait est ce que vous allez mettre en
place le type d'expérimentation que je
viens de vous décrire par exemple dans
les classes de la manière de faire
classe différente et ce sont les
enseignants eux mêmes qui sont les
premiers demandeurs parce que faire la
classe en france c'est épuisant c'est
exténuant beaucoup de personnes beaucoup
d'enseignants sont en burn out pour eu
pour une de ces raisons là à tel point
que il y avait eu une expérience qui
avait été menée par un grand journal un
grand quotidien du soir qui avait
justement fait un échange entre un prof
en allemagne qui avait enseigné une
semaine en france et l' inverse le prof
allemand qui avait enseigné en france a
dit je ne pourriez je ne pourrais pas
enseignée en france c'est non seulement
épuisant exténuant et la manière de
faire cours justement dévore toute mon
énergie est finalement pas beaucoup plus
d'heures à être dans l'établissement que
que en allemagne donc qu'est-ce que vous
comptez faire par rapport à ce type de
méthodes éducatives et surtout vous avez
parlé de la généralisation je pense que
ça c'est un point fondamental parce que
des expérimentations dans l'inconnu
d'état en 30 ans il ya des choses qui
fonctionnent mais ça n'est jamais
généraliser quand est ce que nous aurons
le courage de généraliser ça il ya un
dernier point c'est sur la mixité
sociale vous ai parlé de reproduction
sociale qu'est ce que vous comptez
concrètement mettre en place pour
permettre une réelle mixité sociale dans
nos établissements publics et privés
jeudi et privé parce que de l'argent
public finance en partie les
établissements privés il serait un
minimum de demander des contreparties de
la part de l'état français
d'avoir une forme de mixité sociale à
partir du moment où nous mettons ne
serait ce qu'un centime d'argent public
nous devrions demander des contre des
contreparties sur ceux sur sept ce
besoin de mixité donc est ce que vous
allez engager des actions également à ce
niveau là et enfin deux derniers
intervenantes qui sont derrière leur
écran sabine van heghe et laure darcos
je souhaite évoquer un sujet qui le
préoccupe comme j'en suis certaine qu
quelques chaque
série il s'agit du harcèlement
si personne ne
vous le savez monsieur ministre huit
cent mille et un million d'enfants sont
victimes de harcèlement scolaire et
cyber harcèlement et 21 suicides de
jeunes harcelaient sont malheureusement
à déplorer
je sais que le programme phare est en
cours de généralisation depuis 2000 21
ans et cela lors de mes nombreux
déplacements dans mon département du pas
de calais partout en france et il ya
quelques jours encore à poitiers à la
rencontre de parents de jeunes
d'associations je constate
malheureusement que les enfants les
familles pour affronter au fléau du
harcèlement scolaire se sont totalement
abandonnés toujours aux prises avec
leurs bourreaux et bourg en danger alors
sous le papier la question est prise en
compte mais je dirais uniquement sur le
papier sur le terrain c'est l'omerta
c'est la question tabou c'est le
phénomène qui shell c'est le phénomène
qui trouble la hawtin c'est ce que me
remonter différents acteurs rien ne
bouge et où rien ne bouge pas assez
sabine
le nom de l'affichage les établissements
de l'audience 23 18 pourtant c'est très
facile à mettre en place par des changes
parents professeurs élèves sur ces
questions manque de réactivité des
autorités académiques manque de
personnel médico-social dans les
établissements pourtant ce sont des
propositions au nombre de 35 de la
mission sénat dans
unanime en restait malheureusement
lettres nord alors qu'elles sont très
faciles c'est facile ce ministre à
mettre en oeuvre encore faudrait-il en
avoir la volonté politique alors
monsieur willy je prends vraiment nous
comptons vraiment ce goût pour enfin
prendre à bras le corps ces enjeux
allez-vous prendre dès maintenant des
mesures de type réglementaire le
sentiment d'abandon des enfants des
parents des acteurs confrontés à ce
fléau qui ravage les vies de trous de
jeunes qui pour certains ne trouve
d'autre issue à leur détresse que de
mettre fin à leurs jours merci laure
darcos
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre ne vous inquiétez pas vous
arriver au bout de la rue de ce pensum
de deux questions beaucoup de choses ont
été dites moi je vais juste de questions
extrêmement précises bateau une
questions et une suggestion
monsieur ministre on a beaucoup parlé de
l'institution scolaire et beaucoup a été
fait je me reconnais maintenant nous
avons de grosses grosses demandes au
collège pour créer des classes ulis on a
fait beaucoup à l'école primaire mais
heureusement d'ailleurs finalement ses
enfants en inclusion ont montré qu'ils
étaient capables de passe de passer dans
le secondaire et il ya un vraiment un
besoin criant de deux créations qu'elles
subissent et donc je voulais voir le
sourire deuxième ronde c'était une
suggestion 1 go prédécesseur en 2008
avait remis la fédération de la grande
distribution au pouvoir dresser une
liste de fournitures indispensables
en cette période de pouvoir des
problèmes de propre pouvoir d'achat et
d'inflation je vous dis ça parce que je
ne peux pas malheureusement transposer
cette suggestion
un amendement dans le projet doit
pouvoir d'achat je le regrette mais je
vous suggère de pouvoir peut-être faire
la même chose et réunir tous ces
dirigeants de la fédération de la grande
distribution ils s'étaient mis d'accord
sur une liste de fournitures
indispensables à bas prix ce qui
permettait quand même assez tous ces
parents d'élèves qui
vraiment un look de ces vacances sont
inquiets de savoir si les mois voire les
moyens de pouvoir payer toutes ses
fournitures à leurs enfants à la rentrée
de pouvoir avoir une liste de
fournitures indispensables
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur mini voilà
le ministre la dernière série de
questions
je vous remercie
pour toutes ces questions auxquelles je
vais m'efforcer de répondre mesdames et
messieurs en commençant par
la question madame la sénatrice
relatives à parcours sup et vous a fait
fait état de situations compliquées
alors un mot sur parcours sup
c'est un dispositif qui est perfectible
au sens où d'année en année nous
améliorons les choses et pour cette
année à la fois dans son fonctionnement
je dirais techniques et également dans
sa grande architecture
algorithmique parcours sup à bien mieux
fonctionné que l'année dernière donc on
est on progresse d'année en année là
dessus c'est un système qui est
améliorable et qui s'améliore nous
sommes actuellement dans la phase
complémentaire de parcours sud de telle
sorte que chaque candidat
a parcours sub qui est à ceux à ce jour
sans solution fait l'objet d'un
accompagnement personnalisé
on est là dans ce dans ce déploiement
est donc je si vous voulez bien me
donnez les
tout à l'heure peut-être des
coordonnées en tout cas les précisions
sur les jeunes en question nous allons
regarder cela mais nous sommes dans la
phase d'un accompagnement personnalisé
jeu je parcours sud n'est pas parfait
mais j'entends parfois
des ce n'est pas vous mais des personnes
qui regrette la situation avant parcours
sup qui n'était absolument pas
absolument pas juste avec une course à
l'inscription dans les universités avec
ça et là même des tirages au sort pour
déterminer les entrées dans tel ou tel
établissement et donc il faut prendre
parcours sup et améliorer
progressivement parcours sup mais ce
dispositif représente une amélioration
articulée à la réforme du lycée à la
réforme du bac dont on n'a pas encore
toute la mesure puisque la crise
sanitaire a complètement paralysé les
deux précédentes éditions on a enfin un
bac qui s'est déroulée dans des
conditions à peu près normale avec
simplement le report des épreuves de
spécialités de mars à mai ce qui a eu un
effet sur parcours su puisque les
épreuves de spécialités n'ont pas pu
être prises en compte dans dans parcours
sup donc on est encore dans une
situation qui est
qui n'est pas complètement stabilisé
mais on progresse vraiment et il y a de
quoi être
tout à fait optimiste sur les résultats
de parcours sup lorsque l'ensemble
fonctionnera au mieux sur les abs h je
crois que c'était vous monsieur le
sénateur vial qui soulignait ce point
qu'un point effectivement tout à fait
essentiel on y est très sensible en
recherche une solution pour les aes h
qui
dispose d'un seul d'un seul
employeur ce qui est évident c'est qu'il
faut travailler avec les collectivités
pour
à la fois éviter les ruptures
d'accompagnement des élèves sur le temps
périscolaire et notamment la pause
méridienne je suis très sensible de ce
point de vue au fait que sur les 400
mille jeunes à
besoins particuliers 10% environ
présentent des troubles autistiques et
les jeunes dans cette situation doivent
avoir une grande régularité dans
l'accompagnement et certainement pas des
ruptures méridienne ou autre et donc il
faut il faut trouver une solution
juridique et augmenter le temps de
travail des abbesses h qui le souhaitent
c'est très compliqué d'un point de vue
juridique ça j'en suis bien j'en suis
bien conscient
mais il faut trouver une solution et on
va trouver une solution pour pour
résoudre ce ce problème
on
va y arriver sur la jeunesse et la vie
associative
en effet
le paysage institutionnel a changé je
dirais que la job ce vin a un rôle
d'autant plus important que ce rôle est
transversal et que ce rôle et inter
ministérielle du côté de matignon
puisque madame schiappa est rattachée à
la première ministre du côté du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
du côté aussi du ministère des armées
pour ce qui concerne la le s est nu nous
sommes en discussion entre ministères
pour trouver la bonne formule mais je
crois que cet inter
ministériel it et si je puis dire et
positive une fois passées les
investissements en temps et en et en
réglage
pour éviter
les effets de silos et faire que les
choses fonctionnent au mieux
madame la sénatrice
drexler je crois sur la ruralité je
crois que c'est vous qui me il y a nous
ne sommes pas nous sommes très sensibles
aux questions de deux liés à la ruralité
et a parfois des territoires qui sont
éloignés de l'école et de dispositifs
qui peuvent exister en zone urbaine mais
il existe bien des dispositifs avec les
les
l'éclat qui sont récents je crois qu'ils
ont été mises en place à partir de
l'automne 2021 réellement donc il n'y en
a pas encore beaucoup
et avec les territoires éducatifs ruraux
qui font partie aussi de la politique
d'éducation
prioritaire la question des taux
d'encadrement elle est pas véritablement
centrale parce qu'on a des bons taux
d'encadrement mais il ya d'autres
questions qui relèvent qu'ils peuvent
relever de là politique d'éducation
prioritaire soyez assurés que les
territoires ruraux ne sont pas oubliés
dans notre réflexion
à propos
des
je crois que c'était monsieur le
sénateur à coups aussi si je ne suis pas
très sûr
jeu ce qui j'ai été sensible à votre
point sur des enseignants en situation
de désarroi face à des élèves j'ai
mentionné moi même des situations face
aux parents dans mon propos liminaire ce
qui est certain et là je m'inscris dans
la continuité avec jean michel blanquer
c'est que nous ne pratiquons pas la
politique de l'autruche sur ce sujet où
la politique de la poussière sous le
tapis nous saisissons les situations
quand nous avons à les connaître et nous
les affrontons et donc je serai
d'ailleurs très heureux d'échanger avec
vous sur si vous avez des exemples
précis à à me fournir ce qui est certain
c'est que la politique de l'autruche
n'est absolument pas la nôtre sur la
question
du harcèlement scolaire
il est évident que c'est une question
pardon je crois que c'était vous madame
la sénatrice c'est une question
essentielle alors on a une politique qui
va être une politique d'affichage
beaucoup plus vigoureuse à partir de la
rentrée d'affichage des numéros appelés
je conçois que sur le terrain les choses
ne semblent pas très avancé et donc il
faut absolument que on avance c'est que
on voit la différence mais pardon
en médecine scolaire
il faut il faut absolument faire de
telle sorte que le harcèlement scolaire
et c'est une priorité c'est une priorité
d'ailleurs de mon prédécesseur je ne
change pas
deux points de vue là dessus des équipes
valeurs de la république existe déjà
dans chaque académie elles sont à
disposition des enseignants lorsqu'ils
lorsqu'un incident est signalé relatif à
une atteinte - signalement disons à la
laïcité et donc ces équipes là elles
interviennent alors c'est à la fois des
rendez vous téléphoniques ou des rendez
vous sur place pour accompagner les
équipes dirigeantes et les équipes
d'enseignants lorsqu'une difficultés se
posent ou lorsque un besoin se pose un
vade-mecum très complet a été a été
publié sur les questions de laïcité et
j'ai indiqué que ses équipes pouvaient
être ponctuellement renforcée selon les
besoins formulés par les académies
genre je
rebondis peut-être directement sur une
question qui m'a été posée à propos des
données je crois que c'était vous madame
la sénatrice nous publions des données
trimestrielles
donc les pubs les données de mars de
décembre à mars ont été publiés on va
bientôt sortir les données de mars à
juin j'ai décidé que ces données
seraient de nam ans dorénavant des
données mensuelles à partir du mois de
septembre ce sont des données qui sont
des données du ministère de l'éducation
nationale qui sont des données en fait
plus fine que les données qui sont
fournis du côté du ministère de
l'intérieur à propos des données que
nous avons jusqu'à présent elles
indiquent une stabilité des signalements
-1% bon conte considérons que il y as
stabilité mais une hausse des
signalements pour tenue
dans tenue vestimentaire une hausse de
7% entre pour décembre pour la période
décembre mars ces signalements
constituent 22 % du total et j'attends
avec intérêt évidemment les données pour
la période qui va du mois de mars au
mois de juin nous avons agi nous n'avons
pas attendu ces données il y a les
équipes valeurs de la république nous
sommes en contact très régulier avec ses
équipes il ya le conseil des sages de la
laïcité il ya une documentation il ya
tout un accompagnement et les il y à des
incidents parfois comme ici et là dans
la presse peut se faire l'écho mais
globalement je pense que nous y arrivons
avec toutefois des points de vigilance
dans certains endroits très spécifiques
sur lesquels il faut agir et est bien
entendu que l'autorité il ya des
sanctions qui sont prononcés bien
entendu mais on a un équipement qui a
été construit ces dernières années et
qui est un équipement un équipement tout
à fait
tout à fait solide à propos des
questions de laïcité et je le jeu
m'inscris dans cette danse est dans
cette continuité sur les méthodes
éducatives
monsieur le sénateur chanterelle oui j'y
suis très attentif et je réitère mon
intérêt pour les comparaisons et les
expériences
du côté de la finlande par exemple ou
d'autres pays qui me semble tout à fait
essentiel et j'ai indiqué notre volonté
de de généraliser et d'aller au delà de
l'expérience locale la mixité sociale on
peut y arriver en fixant des objectifs
relatifs au taux de boursiers
du côté des établissements favoriser et
en équipant des équipes des
établissements n'ont favorisé par
exemple avec des sections européennes
plusieurs sections européennes je crois
3 ou 5 de mémoire ont trois sections
européennes ouvrent à la rentrée dans le
département de la seine saint denis
dans des établissements qui ne sont pas
des établissements favorisés donc on a
une double politique augmentation du
taux de boursiers et valorisation
d'établissement peuvent à peu favorisés
par différents différentes choses y
compris donc des sections européennes et
de ce point de vue là les résultats
s'avèrent tout à fait intéressant je
vous invite à voir ce qui se passe du
côté de paris dans le 18e arrondissement
où dans le 12e arrondissement avec des
expériences de mixité conduite par la
mairie de paris mais aussi par le
rectorat qui sont tout à fait
prometteuse
je termine par madame la sénatrice
darcos à propos
des
de ceux de cette suggestion que vous
faisiez madame la sénatrice à propos du
des dirigeants de la grande du monde de
la grande distribution est en effet nous
sommes intervenus à ce sujet en parle à
la publication d'un trousseau de base en
demandant aux enseignants de deux d'être
très comment dirais-je prudent et et il
est sobre dans les demandes
d'équipements et de matériels scolaires
qu'ils vont réclamer à leurs élèves à la
rentrée et en
proposant une sorte de trousseau de base
sur lequel ils peuvent s'appuyer cette
question du pouvoir d'achat elle est
présente dans la circulaire de rentrée
qui a été publiée par le
le ministère et puis enfin pardon d'être
un peu long c'est moi qui suis long en
réalité ce n'est pas ça n'est pas vous
qui l'êtes les classes ulis en collège
et se l'essor important des enfants à
besoins particuliers
vers le collège et puis vers le lycée
puis ensuite vers l'enseignement
supérieur ce qui est une
bonne chose en soi le niveau sur lequel
nous nous penchons plus particulièrement
c'est celui du lycée maintenant avec ce
déplacement pour assurer une continuité
avec les niveaux
écoles élémentaires et collèges et donc
c'est de ce côté là que l'on travaille y
compris d'ailleurs dans la perspective
du bac et de parcours sup il ya un
travail à réaliser aussi avec ma
collègue de l'enseignement supérieur
madame retailleau pour que ces jeunes
puissent être accueillis dans les
meilleures conditions possibles dans
l'enseignement supérieur donc on suit
cela y compris du haut niveau du collège
avec les classes ulis
c'est un
cette question de l'inclusion scolaire
est évidemment une question
absolument importante pour nous c'est
une des grandes réussites des dernières
années il faut la halle à l'accompagner
il faut la la la la sécurisé avec la
question des ash et en même temps faire
attention à cette hausse extrêmement
forte du nombre d'avs et sage donc il
faut réfléchir en lien avec les maisons
départementales du handicap en lien avec
les agences régionales de santé avec
tous les partenaires qui sont les nôtres
pour accompagner l'école inclusive et en
même temps faire que l'effort que nous
faisons soit un effort soutenable dans
le temps et qu'il se fasse au bénéfice
des élèves et de leurs familles
merci de monsieur le ministre je voulais
vous tous été très
attentifs au fait que vous répondiez de
façon très précise haché en justement
pardonnez moi je n'ai pas eu de réponse
des ondes ont alors on va je vais
revenir pardonnez moi madame sûr et je
n'ai pas eu de réponse sur mac et la
question relative à l'autorité comment
comptez-vous rétablir l'autorité dans
les établissements scolaires ensuite
votre position sur l'établissement dur
doublement à fermont puis les pistes
envisagées la proposition d'une carte
qui serait au triennal pour la fermeture
des classes en milieu rural
des gens moi ces trois questions là non
pas une réponse alors rétabli
rétablissement durée du redoublement non
toutes les études internationales tous
les pays où les résultats scolaires sont
bons parfois meilleures que les nôtres
dans certains domaines sont des pays où
leur étable où le redoublement n'existe
pas et il existe encore moins d'ailleurs
qu'en france et donc la question du
redoublement n'est pas une question qui
à elles seules seraient susceptibles de
changer les choses le redoublement
existe mais je crois qu'il serait il
serait erroné de revenir une politique
ancien du redoublement il faut réfléchir
à l'accompagnement des élèves en
situation difficile et c'est une
question qui peut se faire
indépendamment de la question du
redoublement même si sur le fond
évidemment je votre remarque a du sens
sur l'europe pendant sur l'autorité des
enseignants c'est un point que j'ai
indiqué très brièvement dans mon propos
liminaire il ya une il ya l'autorité je
dirai
comment dirais-je la place le statut et
l'autorité des enseignants m'importe
beaucoup ont acquis le suis je suis très
sensible et très
attentif à toutes les formes de violence
symbolique irréel que peuvent subir les
enseignants un titre ou un autre et donc
la question de l'autorité se pose je ne
suis pas du tout laxistes de ce point de
vue là mais la question de l'autorité
des enseignants elle se pose peut-être
un peu différemment du passé ne s'agit
pas de revenir à une période ancienne
qui serait celle d'une autorité voyez
verticale avec des formes de punition ou
tout ce qui a pu exister dans le passé
mais travailler sur le statut des
enseignants sur leurs rémunérations
sur le recrutement des enseignants dans
de meilleures conditions
tout cela et contribuer me semble-t-il
un à cette autorité que nous souhaitons
la formation des enseignants aussi y
compris la formation continue des
enseignants
c'est un élément
d'autorité je suis sensible aussi à la
question des des projets immobiliers on
en a parlé dans en bretagne dans les
côtes du nord de projets immobiliers qui
avaient été consentis par certaines
communes et puis qui se sont heurtés à
la fermeture de classe et donc ça ça
veut dire ça signifie quelque chose ça
signifie qu'il faut avoir une vision un
tout petit peu plus à la moyen terme des
perspectives démographiques pour ne pas
d'année en année se retrouver à chaque
fois dans des situations qui peuvent
être compliqué pour des communes qui
investissent d'un point de vue
immobilier je je je je vous la corde et
donc nous devons
je dirais améliorer et renforcer le
dialogue avec les communes pour
augmenter la visibilité à moyen terme en
particulier la visibilité démographique
mais il y a aussi des accidents
démographique si je puis dire l'arrivée
brutal de plusieurs familles par exemple
où le départ ou une fermeture
d'établissement
commerciale ou industrielle donc il ya
aussi des impondérables mais on doit
pouvoir réfléchir à moyen terme de
manière à ce que les maires et les
municipalités puissent
disons réfléchir sur les investissements
sans se heurter aux difficultés que vous
soulignez à juste titre voilà merci
monsieur me disais que nous avons
apprécié le fait que vous preniez bien
le temps de répondre à chacune des
questions et d'apporter des éléments
précis sur à la fois que la façon dont
vous
concevez les 10 et les problèmes posés
mais aussi les solutions que vous
essayez de 10 à porter vous avez vu que
les sénatrices et sénateurs ils sont
tous très attentifs à la question
scolaire et que nous étions nombreux à
vouloir vous vous interrogez je crois
que ce dialogue avec nous était
important pour vous vous avez compris
qu'il était aussi important pour nous
c'est un premier échange un échange
riche et qui a pris du temps mais qui je
suis sûr
pourra par la suite être complétée par
d'autres par d'autres auditions de cette
nature en tout cas merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre pour le temps que
vous avez consacré à la commission merci
monsieur le président merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
comme
monsieur le président l'indiquait je
suis évidemment à votre disposition pour
poursuivre ces échanges et puis pour les
poursuivre aussi d'une manière
informelle via mon cabinet sachez que
nous sommes évidemment très attentifs
aux remontées au terrain
qui
j'en ai eu plusieurs exemples cet après
midi à vos suggestions à vos travaux je
suis grand lecteur de
rapport très complet que vous publiez
sur les questions relatives à
l'éducation donc sachez que vous avez
aurait avec moi un partenaire attentif
et respectueux de votre travail et de
vos prérogatives
merci
merci beaucoup